ALLEN ARCHULETA ATKINS BATES
BELL GORGEOUS BRADFORD
GABRIELLE CHIANG DALLY DODD
THEY'RE ALSO GALGIANI. GLAZER
GONZALEZ GROVE HERTZBERG HILL
WITH SO. TADO JACKSON JONES
LEYVA MCGUIRE MITCHELL MONNING
MORE LOCKED THE REAL NIELSEN
PAN PORTANTINO ROTH RUBIO
SKINNER STERN STONE NUMBER BY
CASKEY WIENER WILK. MEMBERS A
QUORUM IS PRESENT WHAT OUR
MEMBERS AND OUR GUESTS BEYOND
THE ROLLING IN THE GALLERY
PLEASE RISE WILL BE LET THIS
MORNING IN PRAYER BY OUR JOPLIN
SYSTEM CHAU. GORMAN AFTER WHICH
WILL BE LED IN THE PLEDGE OF
ALLEGIANCE VICE SENATOR.
GONZALEZ. LET US BE CENTERED IN
GOD'S PRESENCE. AND SINCE THIS
IS BACK TO SCHOOL TIME I'D LIKE
TO SHARE THE FOLLOWING POEM BY
SISTER PASSED RYAN OF SAN
FRANCISCO. IT'S CALLED X. I
NEARLY THREW IN THE TOWEL. AS
WAS MAY MY FIRST YEAR TEACHING.
AFTER ALGEBRA CLASS CARLENE
WHISPERED IN MY EAR. SISTER
WHEN ARE WE GOING TO LEARN WHAT
X. IS. CARLENE SO MANY YEARS
LATER I CAN TELL YOU A LOT MORE
ABOUT X. IT NOT ONLY MARKS THE
SPOT. IT SYMBOLIZES EVERY
UNKNOWN ANY MYSTERY. IT'S THE
LATTER THAT EVERYONE IS LOOKING
FOR. I'VE LEARNED SO MUCH SINCE
USE DONE TO ME WITHOUT QUESTION.
MY ANSWER RIGHT NOW WOULD BE
NEVER. WE ARE NEVER GOING TO
LEARN WHAT X. IS. IS THE
NAMELESS ESSENCE OF AN ETERNAL
SEARCH THE MAGNET PULLING THE
EVOLUTIONARY PROCESS. IT IS
TOTALLY AVAILABLE AND OPEN TO
ANY BRAIN BUT NEEDS A MARKER TO
HOLD ON TO THE INFINITE TO
REALITY PASSING THROUGH. WE ARE
NEVER GOING TO LEARN WHAT X. IS
BUT WE WILL NEVER STOP TRYING.
GOD BEYOND ALL KNOWLEDGE GIVE
US THE GRACE TO ALWAYS REMEMBER
THOSE WE ARE STUDENTS OF
MYSTERY A MAN. PLEASE JOIN ME
IN SALUTING OUR NATION'S FLAG.
I LEDGE ALLEGIANCE TO THE FLAG
OF THE UNITED STATES OF AMERICA
AND. AND ONE THING INDIVISIBLE
WITH LIBERTY AND JUSTICE FOR
ALL. RIGHT. MEMBERS ON THE
PRIVILEGE OF THE FLOOR WE HAVE
HONOR TODAY TO RECOGNIZE
PRESIDENT NELSON FROM
SACRAMENTO STATE. AND HE'S WITH
US TODAY CELEBRATING THE SENATE
FELLOWS PROGRAM SAC STATE IS A
PROUD PARTNER WITH THE SENATE
ON THIS DISTINGUISHED PROGRAM.
SENATOR NELSON. I ME PRESIDENT
NELSON I GAVE YOUR PROMOTION OR
DEMOTION PROS A DEMOTION.
PRESIDENT NELSON. NEXT UP WE
HAVE CITY PROTIUM ATKINS. AND
THIS GROWTH AND SENATOR GROVE
RECOGNIZING OUR FELLS. THE
MORNING. THANK YOU MISTER
PRESIDENT. I'M PLEASED TO BE
JOINED BY THE REPUBLICAN LEADER
TODAY AS WE ACKNOWLEDGE THE
CONTRIBUTIONS IN THE SERVICE OF
OUR TWENTY EIGHTEEN NINETEEN
CALIFORNIA STATE FELLOWS WHO
WILL BE DEPARTING AT THE END OF
SESSION. THE FELLOWS PROGRAM IS
JOINTLY OPERATED BY THE SENATE
AND THE CENTER FOR CALIFORNIA
TUDIES AT SACRAMENTO STATE
UNIVERSITY GO HORNETS.
ESTABLISHED IN NINETEEN SEVENTY
THREE THE PROGRAM GREW OUT OF A
DESIRE TO PROVIDE COLLEGE
GRADUATES. OF DIVERSE AGES
EXPERIENCES AND BACKGROUNDS
WITH INSIGHT INTO OUR
LEGISLATIVE PROCESS. AS THEY
GAIN EXPOSURE TO THE LEDGE
PROCESS OUR FELLOWS PROVIDE
MEMBERS AND THE SENATE POLICY
COMMITTEES WITH VALUABLE STAFF
ASSISTANCE. FELLOWS BRING A
VERY SPECIAL ENERGY AND
ENTHUSIASM INTO OUR OFFICES.
THEY'RE EAGER TO LEARN QUICK TO
HELP AND BRING A PASSION TO OUR
WORK THAT'S REFRESHING AND
INSPIRING TO WATCH. WE AND THE
PEOPLE OF CALIFORNIA HAVE BEEN
WELL SERVED BY THE PRESENCE OF
THESE EXCEPTIONAL INDIVIDUALS
IN FACT MY VERY OWN CHIEF OF
STAFF NAY CARMEN STARTED OUT
AND WAS A FORMER FELLOW AND I'M
SURE THAT IS TRUE OF MANY OF
YOU HERE. IN TERMS OF THE STAFF
THAT YOU HAVE WHO'S GONE ON TO
DO. REALLY INCREDIBLE THINGS SO
I'M PLEASED AGAIN TO BE JOINED
BY SENATOR GROW IN INTRODUCING
THE SENATE FELLOWS AND
PRESENTING THEM WITH
RESOLUTIONS COMMENDING THEIR
EXEMPLARY SERVICE. FOR US
SENATOR BREAUX OF THE- WELL.
THANK YOU THANK YOU MADAM FOR
TIM I APPRECIATE THE HONOR TO
BE ABLE TO STAND WITH YOU AN
HONOR OUR FELLOWS AND THIS
MORNING THE SENATE FELLOW PUTS
PROGRAM IS ONE OF THE MOST
PRESTIGIOUS AND SUCCESSFUL
PROGRAMS THIS TYPE IN THE
NATION WE DRAW APPLICANTS NOT
JUST FROM CALIFORNIA BUT
THROUGHOUT THE COUNTRY WE
RECEIVED OVER FOUR HUNDRED
APPLICATIONS EACH YEAR AND THE
ACCEPTANCE INTO THIS PROGRAM.
IS VERY COMPETITIVE AND IS PART
OF THE CAPITAL FELLOWS PROGRAM
FOR FOUR CONSECUTIVE YEARS
RUNNING THE CALIFORNIA SENATE
FELLOWS HAVE BEEN RANKED AS ONE
OF THE TOP TEN INTERNSHIPS IN
THE COUNTRY ALONG WITH GOOGLE
IN THE SMITHSONIAN THE
FELLOWSHIP EXPERIENCE BROADENS
PERSPECTIVES OF THOSE PLANNING
ACADEMIC AND PRIVATE SECTOR
GOVERNMENT CAREERS SO THAT THEY
CAN CARRY INTO THEIR CHOSEN
FIELD AND ENTER STANDING OF THE
LEGISLATIVE PROCESS AND HOW TO
PACKED AND DEVELOP PUBLIC
POLICY IN ADDITION TO THE
OFFICE PLACE IT'S AN ACADEMIC
CAM ON IT IS AN INTEGRAL PART
OF THE FELLOWS PROGRAM. THE
CELLS ARE IN THE SCRIPT WITH
STUDENTS AT SACRAMENTO STATE
AND EARNED SIX UNITS OF CREDIT
AND IT'S OUR PLEASURE ADD TO
INTRODUCE THE TWO THOUSAND
EIGHTEEN NINETEEN SENATE
FELLOWS SENATORS PLEASE JOIN US
IN THE BACK FOR ME ENERGY SURE
FELLOW TO TAKE A PHOTOGRAPH
WITH THAT INDIVIDUAL. IT'S BEEN
IN YOUR OFFICE FOR THE LAST FEW
MINUTES. AND THIS WAS OUR
POINTED OUT TO ME BY ONE OF OUR
COLLEAGUES SENATOR GROW
MENTIONED OVER FOUR HUNDRED
APPLICATIONS IT'S A VERY
COMPETITIVE PROGRAM. I WANT TO
ADD MY APPRECIATION OUR
APPRECIATION. TO THE MEMBERS OF
OUR STAFF THAT HELPED DO THAT
SELECTION PROCESS AND READ FOUR
HUNDRED APPLICATIONS. IT'S AN
INCREDIBLE PROCESS WE WANT TO
THANK THEM FOR THEIR WORK IN
BRINGING US THE BRIGHTEST AND
THE BEST. AND WITH THAT. IT'S
MY PLEASURE NOW TO INTRODUCE
THE FOLLOWING FELLOWS. ZAIRE
BAILEY HE GRADUATED FROM
SPELMAN COLLEGE WITH A
BACHELOR'S DEGREE IN POLITICAL
SCIENCE AND WORK FOR SENATOR
ROBERT HERTZBERG
. EMILY CORNET.
EMILY GRADUATE YOU CLAP EMILY
GRADUATED. WITH A BACHELOR'S
DEGREE IN INTERNATIONAL AFFAIRS
FROM LEWIS AND CLARK COLLEGE
SHE WORK FOR IS IN THE OFFICE
OF SENATOR MIKE MCGUIRE. MEGAN
THIS IS MEGAN GRADUATED FROM UC
IRVINE WITH A BACHELOR'S DEGREE
IN BUSINESS ADMINISTRATION AND
IS WORKING FOR SENATOR JOHN
MORLOCK
. CASSIDY DENNY CASSIDY
GRADUATED WITH A BACHELOR'S
DEGREE IN BUSINESS
ADMINISTRATION FROM COLORADO
STATE UNIVERSITY AND HAS BEEN
WORKING WITH SENATOR SCOTT
WIENER. MEANER HANAN MEAN A
GRADUATED FROM UC RIVERSIDE
WITH A BACHELOR'S DEGREE IN
POLITICAL SCIENCE AND WORKS
WITH SENATOR BEEN ALLEN.
JENNIFER CAKE JENNIFER IS A
GRADUATE OF PITZER COLLEGE IN
HAS A BACHELOR'S DEGREE IN
ANTHROPOLOGY AND ASIAN AMERICAN
STUDIES JENNIFER IS WORKING FOR
THE PUBLIC SAFETY COMMITTEE.
CARNEY KING CARNEY IS A
GRADUATE OF THE UNIVERSITY OF
OREGON WITH A BACHELOR'S DEGREE
IN POLITICAL SCIENCE CARNEY IS
WORKING WITH SENATOR MIKE
MORRELL. NICE. HEY LESLIE ELLIS
GRADUATED FROM UC DAVIS WITH A
DEGREE IN PSYCHOLOGY AND HAS
BEEN WORKING OR IS WORKING WITH
SENATOR CONNIE LEIVA. CLEAR
MARKS. CLEAR EARNED A
BACHELOR'S DEGREE IN POLITICAL
SCIENCE FROM UC RIVERSIDE AND
IS IT IS WORKING IN THE OFFICE
OF SENATOR JEFF STONE. YOU'RE
GOING. MATCHES. ON BEHALF OF MY
COLLEAGUES A BIG FAKE OOPS I'M
TURN IT BACK OVER TO YOU
SENATOR THANK YOU AM MADAM PRO
TEM SO THE NEXT GROUP OF
FELLOWS THAT WE'RE GOING TO
BRING UP START WITH ABRAHAM AND
DOES IT THE THIRD HE COS A YOU
SACRAMENTO AND HE HAS A
BACHELOR'S DEGREE IN SOCIAL
WORK AND HE WORKED FOR SENATOR
BEN HUESO. CHRISTOPHER MORALIS
CSU SAN MARCOS A BACHELOR
DEGREE IN CRIMINAL JUSTICE AND
SOCIOLOGY AND HE WORKED FOR
SENATOR STEVEN BRADFORD. DEL
FURRED SMITH THE THIRD LAYOVER
MERRY MIND A BACHELOR'S DEGREE
IN COMMUNICATION STUDIES AND HE
WORKED FOR SENATOR ANNA CABIN
HERO. DEAN TALLY AT SACRAMENTO
STATE BACHELOR'S DEGREE IN
COMMUNICATIONS AND HE WORKED
FOR SENATOR JIM NIELSEN.
MCKINLEY THOMPSON MORLEY SAN
DIEGO STATE UNIVERSITY A
BACHELORS IN POLITICAL SCIENCE
AND HE WORKED FOR SENATOR
STEVEN GLAZER. FRANK THOMPSON
SACRAMENTO STATE DOCTORS AGREE
IN ENGLISH LANGUAGE AND HE
WORKED FOR SENATOR SCOTT WILK.
AHEAD TO RYO TOSUN ONIH UCLA
BACHELOR'S DEGREE IN ENGLISH
LITERATURE AND SHE WORKED FOR
SENATOR HOLLY MITCHELL.
WILLIAMS UC DAVIS LECTURES
DEGREE IN POLITICAL SCIENCE AND
PSYCHOLOGY AND HE HE WORKED FOR
SENATOR NANCY SKINNER. BLAKE
ZANTE CSU FRESNO BACHELOR'S
DEGREE IN POLITICAL SCIENCE AND
HE WORKED FOR SENATOR ANDREAS
BOARD CHEST. I'D LIKE TO THINK
THAT SENATE PROTEIN FROM
ALLOWING ME TO PARTICIPATE AND
ALTERNATE BACK OVER TO OUR
LEADER AND WE'RE GONNA AT EXIT
AND TAKE A PICTURE ON THE
STAIRS Là. THE REPUBLICAN
LEADER AND I IN THE FELLOWS BUT
ANY BODY NOTICE I REALIZE THAT
IT IS THE BIRTHDAY WEEK OF THE
SENATOR FROM BERKELEY BUT- TWO
FELLOWS I MEAN I. NOT THAT NOT
THAT WE'RE PAYING ATTENTION AND
TAKE A NOTE SENATOR. BUT. THIS
THIS COULD GO WRONG VERY
QUICKLY BUT LET LET ME JUST SAY
WHAT AN INCREDIBLE GROUP BEFORE
US. HI AND IT IT YOU STILL HAVE
A NUMBER OF WEEKS TO GO SO WE
WILL CELEBRATE YOU TODAY WHILE
WE'RE STILL FRESH AND HAPPY.
BUT WE KNOW AS THE SESSION
CONTINUES FORWARD THAT IT'S
GONNA BE. THE HIGHLIGHT OF YOUR
TIME WITH US ALL THE WORK THAT
YOU HAVE PUT IN FOR YOUR-
REPRESENTATIVE I IS REALLY
GOING TO COME DO AS WE CLOSE
OUT THE SESSION. BUT WE
COULDN'T THANK YOU ENOUGH FOR
THE WORK IN THE ENTHUSIASM AND
WHAT YOU'VE DONE FOR THE
RESIDENTS NOT JUST OUR FOR OUR
OFFICES BUT FOR THE RESIDENTS
OF CALIFORNIA. AND ARMY
KNOWLEDGE JAMIE BACK THERE. FOR
THE WORK THAT YOU HAVE DONE.
AND LAST BUT NOT LEAST WE CAN
STILL ENJOY THE CELEBRATION AND
I WILL JOIN I WILL INVITE MY
COLLEAGUES TO JOIN US IN ROOM
TWO ELEVEN. FOR RECEPTION WITH
THE FELLOWS AND THEIR GAS AS WE.
WIND DOWN SESSION TODAY THANK
YOU. THANK. WHICH AGAIN IS IN
IT CONGRATULATIONS TO THESE
WALL DESERVING FOLLOWS WHO HAVE
SERVED AS WELL OVER THE LAST
FEW MONTHS. THEY WILL BE TAKING
A PICTURE AND THE BACK OF
OUTSIDE TO CHAMBER WITH THE
LEADERSHIP. SENATOR NELSON ON
THE PRIVILEGE OF THE FLOOR. AT
THIS PRESENT LATE CHEN THE
SENATE ID LIKE TO EXERCISE THE
PRIVILEGE OF THE FLOOR FOR JUST
BRIEF COMMENTS REGARDING THE
FELLOWS. HAVING BEEN HERE A
LAWN SERVICE CENTER NELSON
LET'S WAIT FOR THEM TO EXERT
REAL QUICK SO YOU GET SOME.
QUIET. I HAD THE PRIVILEGE OF
KNOWING MANY FELLOWS EVEN
HAVING SOME PLACE IN MY OFFICE.
BUT I'VE WATCHED THE IMPACT
THAT THEY HAVE HAD THESE
FELLOWS ON THIS INSTITUTION.
CERTAINLY THEY HAVE AN IMPACT
WHILE THEY ARE WITH US WORKING
DIRECTLY HERE. BUT EVER SO MANY
HAVE HAD A GREATER IMPACT ON
THE INSTITUTION AFTER THEY LEFT.
MANY HAVE BECOME LEGISLATORS.
AND OTHER HIGH LEVEL POSITIONS
IN LIFE. AND I ALWAYS ENCOURAGE
THEM WHEN THEY TAKE THAT
RESOLUTION AND THEY HANG IT ON
THE WALL. PROJECT THIRTY YEARS
HENCE. AND CONTEMPLATE WHAT
THIS YEAR WE'LL HAVE MEANT.
WHERE THEY ARE THAT PARTICULAR
DAY. THIS IS ONE OF THE PREMIER
PROGRAMS AND IT KNOWLEDGE WHICH
OF THE GREATNESS OF THE
CALIFORNIA STATE LEGISLATURE
THE KINDS OF INDIVIDUALS THAT
WE MENTOR. GET ON THE RIGHT
TRACK OF LIFE AND THEN ENJOY
THEIR CONTRIBUTIONS GIVING BACK
THANK YOU MISTER PRESIDENT.
EXTERNAL SO IN. STILL IN A
BRUTAL FLOORS CENTER WINNER ARE
YOU PREPARED
. SENATOR SENATOR
MITCHELL FOR PURPOSES.
PRIVILEGES OF THE FLOOR YES
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ON MONDAY
WE PAUSE TO ACKNOWLEDGE SOME
BIRTHDAYS THAT OCCURRED DURING
ARE. SUMMER RECESS AND WE FAIL
TO ACKNOWLEDGE FROM MY
PERSPECTIVE A PRETTY
SIGNIFICANT ONE YOU KNOW OUR
PRO TIM IS A TWIN. AND SHE SAYS
THIS THERE'S NEVER AN ODD IT'S
ALWAYS BEEN A WE IN HER LIFE SO
SHE AND HER TWIN CELEBRATE
THEIR BIRTHDAY DURING OUR
SUMMER RECESS AND SO I THOUGHT
IT WAS IMPORTANT FOR US TO WISH
OUR PRO TIM. A BELATED HAPPY
BIRTHDAY. THANK YOU FOR THE
DESERVING RECOGNITION CENTER
WINNER. THANK YOU VERY MUCH AS
THE PRESIDENT NOT BECAUSE THEY
WANT TO RECOGNIZE A GREAT
LEADER IN THE ARTS WORLD IN SAN
FRANCISCO DOES OF A BODY JOSEPH
IS A QUEER ARTIST WHO'S BEEN
CREATING ART IN SAN FRANCISCO
SINCE NINETEEN SEVENTY EIGHT
HIS AT A LONG CAREER IN DESIGN
AND AS ARTISTIC DIRECTOR BUT A
NUMBER OF YEARS AGO HE LEFT THE
CORPORATE WORLD AND DECIDED TO
DEVOTE HIMSELF. TO ARTS AND
PARTICULARLY TO PROMOTING LOCAL
ARTISTS AND MANY OF OUR CITIES
ARTISTS STRUGGLE IT'S NOT EASY
TO GO UP BY ABOUT ARTISTS SOMUCH TO OUR COMMUNITY WE BE
JOSEPH HAS ALSO BEEN AN AMAZING
PARTNER TO OUR OFFICE AND HE
ARE CURATES ART SHOWS IN OUR
OFFICE WHERE WE IN BY. LOCAL
ARTISTS WITH DIFFERENT TEAMS TO
DISPLAY THEIR AND WE HAVE
WONDERFUL ART SHOWS EVERY FEW
MONTHS AND THOSE ARE SHOWS
TYPICALLY RELATE TO EITHER A
COMMUNITY OR ITS TO LEGISLATIVE
WORK THAT WE'RE DOING AND IT'S
A WONDERFUL WAY COULD TO
CONNECT MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC
COME INTO A BUDGET OF ALL OF
THIS. AND TO SEE AMAZING ARE
BUT ALSO. TO BEING DATES AND SO
MUCH OF THE WORLD. DOING. YOU
HAVE I HAD SEVEN OURS SHOWS IN
OUR OFFICE IN THE DISTRICT THAT
I JOSEPH IS CURATED RELATING TO
WITH TEAMS HOUSING THE
ENVIRONMENT NIGHT LIFE SHOWS
HIGHLIGHTING LGBT Q. ARTISTS
AND IS AN AMERICAN ARTISTS AND
HE'S CURRENTLY ORGANIZING
ANOTHER SHOW TO HIGHLIGHT LINE
X. ARTISTS IN SAN FRANCISCO THE
SIDE PEOPLE HAVE TO APPLY IT'S
BECOME VERY COMPETITIVE PEOPLE
STOP ME ON THE STREET THE
APPLYING TO HAVE MY ARE SHOWN
IN YOUR OFFICE SO IT'S VERY
FLATTERING TO ME BUT IT IS ALL
DOES ITS WORK AND HIS
BRILLIANCE AND HIS CONNECTIONS
AND SO PLEASE JOIN ME AND.
RECOGNIZED IN JOE'S OF A BODY
FOR IS AMAZING WORK
.
CONGRADULATIONS ROBOTIC.
SENATOR DR FOR PURPOSE YES
MISTER PRESIDENT UNDER
PRIVILEGES OF THE FLOOR I HAVE
THE HONOR AND PRIVILEGE IS A
PRIVILEGE OF SITTING NEXT TO
NOT ONLY OUR NEWEST MEMBER OF
THE SENATE NOT ONLY APPARENTLY
A BRILLIANT SOFTBALL PLAYER
WITH TWO HITS LAST NIGHT. BUT
TOMORROW. MY SEAT MATE WILL BE
GETTING MARRIED. AND SHE WILL
BE GETTING MARRIED AS THE FIRST
COUPLE TO BE MARRIED IN THE NEW
LONG BEACH CITY HALL. ADAM WITH
WHOM SHE HAS A SHARED LIFE FOR
THE LAST SEVEN YEARS GOD ONLY
KNOWS WHAT SHE WANTS TO GET
MARRIED NOW I DID MY BEST. TO
DISABUSE HER OF THAT BUT
TOMORROW SHE WILL BECOME. A
OFFICIALLY A WIFE AND I HOPE
THAT YOU WILL JOIN ME IN
WISHING HER THE BEST AND A
HEARTY MILES APART. SENATOR
UMBERG WHAT. THANK YOU MISTER
PRESIDENT AND COLLEAGUES WE ALL
WANT TO PAY VERY CLOSE
ATTENTION TO THIS BECAUSE- WITH
ME TODAY ARE THE COMMISSIONERS
FROM THE FAIR POLITICAL
PRACTICES ACT SEES ME FAIR
POLITICAL PRACTICES COMMISSION.
THE OTHER WORDS YET PPC TO
CELEBRATE THEIR FORTY FOURTH
FORTY FIFTH ANNIVERSARY OF
THEIR ORGANIZATIONS CREATION
AND THE WORK THEY DO FOR OUR
ELECTIONS IN OUR DEMOCRACY. IN
NINETEEN SEVENTY FOUR
CALIFORNIA VOTERS
OVERWHELMINGLY VOSE VOICE THEIR
DESIRE FOR GREATER FAIRNESS AND
TRANSPARENCY. IN OUR LIKE TOTAL
SYSTEM OF THE PASSAGE OF
PROPOSITION NINE THIS BALLOT
MEASURE ESTABLISH BOTH THE
CALIFORNIA FAIR POLITICAL
PRACTICES COMMISSION IN A
POLITICAL REFORM ACT OF
NINETEEN SEVENTY FOUR. EVERY
TWO YEARS NEARLY ONE BILLION
DOLLARS IS SPENT ON CALIFORNIA
ELECTIONS AND ALL OF IT
PUBLICLY DISCLOSED TO THE
VOTERS THANKS THE AMAZING WORK
OF THE PPC AND ITS PARTNERS.
THROUGH THE A. P. P.'S WORK ON
CAMPAIGN FINANCE LOBBYING INCONFLICT OF INTEREST
DISCLOSURES VOTERS ARE MORE
INFORMED AND BETTER ABLE TO
HOLD THEIR PUBLIC OFFICIALS
ACCOUNTABLE. JOINING US TODAY
MEMBERS ARE THE CURRENT
COMMISSIONERS OF THE FAIR
POLITICAL PRACTICES COMMISSION
IN THERE ARE OBSERVING TO SEA
LEVEL OF ENTHUSIASM AMONG ALL
OF US HERE TODAY TO SO YOU
KNOW. COMMISSIONER AND SHARE A
RICHARD MATT H. COMMISSIONER
CARE FRANK TRIBUNALS.
COMMISSIONER ALLISON HAYWARD.
AND COMMISSIONER BRIAN HATCH.
THERE WE GO
. THANK YOU
COMMISSIONERS FOR YOUR SERVICE
.
SENATOR WINNER. I FOR PURPOSE
OF RECOGNITION. COLLEAGUES UP
PLEASE TURNER TENS IN THE
GALLERY THE OUR JOIN TODAY BY
OUR INTERNS FROM THE SAN
FRANCISCO DEMOCRATIC PARTY WHO
WERE VISITING THE CAPITOL TODAY
TO LEARN ABOUT OUR LEGISLATIVE
PROCESS AND HAVE SOME MEETINGS
AS A FORMER CHAIR OF THE SAN
FRANCISCO DEMOCRATIC PARTY I
KNOW HOW IMPORTANT THESE
INTERNS ARE FOR THE FUNCTIONING
OF THE ORGANIZATION AND SO IT'S
OF A WARM SENATE WELCOME. TO
OUR SAN FRANCISCO DEMOCRATIC
PARTY INTERNS. WELCOME TO YOUR
STATE CAPITOL. SIR MCGUIRE.
THANK YOU SO MUCH MISTER
PRESIDENT MEMBERS UNDER
PRIVILEGES OF THE FLOOR I AM
PLEASED TO BE ABLE TO INTRODUCE
TODAY THE FUTURE LEADERS THE
FUTURE LEADERS OF THE DAIRY
INDUSTRY HERE IN THE GOLDEN
STATE THEY ARE THROUGH THE
WESTERN UITED DAIRIES ANNUAL
JERRY LEADERS PROGRAM THEY HAIL
FROM EVERY CORNER OF CALIFORNIA
AND THEY ARE UTTERLY EXCITED TO
BE TO BE WITH US IN THE CAPITAL
IN WITH US IN THE SENATE LADIES
AND GENTLEMAN LOOKING ASSN THE
PLEASE STAND THAT'S GIVE THEM A
WARM. CALIFORNIA STATE SENATE
WELCOME. SENATOR DODD. THE
PRESIDENT MEMBERS OF THE
CONDITION OF THE FILE NEXT.
PRIVILEGE OR A CAN. SO YEAH
MEMBERS A WE GOT WE GOT A
LINGUISTICS LESSON IN THE LAST
SIX ON MONDAY I BELIEVE FROM MY
GOOD COLLEAGUE FROM SIDE DIEGO.
ADD HILL HE TAUGHT US ABOUT THE
PROPER PRONUNCIATION OF LATINO
NAMES. ADD IT IT I REALLY
APPRECIATE THOSE LESSONS
BECAUSE THESE LINGUISTIC
LESSONS ARE VERY VERY IMPORTANT
TO ALL OF US THAT WE DO A VERY
VERY GOOD JOB IN THIS REGARD
PRONOUNCING THESE VERY
IMPORTANT NAMES. WELL IT TURNS
OUT THAT MR TWILL WAS. THE
BRIGHT HAD DONE HIS HOMEWORK
BECAUSE MS AG G. R. CURRY IS
NOT MISS AGUILAR CURRY BECAUSE
SHE'S NOT THE TINA SHE'S A
PORTUGUESE SO I'D LIKE TO
CONGRATULATE MR WILL. ON HIS
LESSON TO ALL OF US IN KNOWING
AND UNDERSTANDING THE
LINGUISTICS OF THE PORTUGUESE
NAME TAG WE ARE CURRY. THANK
WAS TO DIE. ZERO IS STILL. THE
WHOLE I WILL KNOW FOLLOW FOR TO
GAUGE. OUR MEMBERS MOVING ODDS
ITEM FOR MESSAGES FROM THE
GOVERNOR WILL BE REAMED DEEMED
READ MESSAGES FROM THE ASSEMBLY
WILL BE DEEMED READ REPORTS
FROM THE COMMITTEE WILL BE
DEEMED READ AND AMENDMENTS
ADOPTED MOTIONS RESOLUTIONS AND
NOTICES. SENATOR DOT. UNDER
BUSH'S RESOLUTION I REQUEST
UNANIMOUS CONSENT TO RETURN SB
TWO THIRTY TWO FILE ON THE ITEM
NUMBER FOURTEEN TO THE ASSEMBLY
FOR FUTURE ACTION. REALLY NOTED.
YEAH AND ONE MORE MISTER.
PRESIDENT UNDER MOTIONS AND
RESOLUTIONS REQUESTED AB
EIGHTEEN TWENTY FIVE FILE ITEM
NUMBER TWO SEVENTY EIGHT IN A
BE EIGHTEEN TWENTY SEVEN FILE
ITEM NUMBER TWO SEVENTY NINE TO
BE REMOVED FROM THE CONSENT
CALENDAR IN PLACE A THIRD
READING AT THE REQUEST OF THE
AUTHOR. HE NOTED. SERIAL THANK
YOU MISTER PRESIDENT THE PLEASE
REMOVE FILE ITEM. TWO FIVE NINE
EIGHTY SIX FORTY SEVEN FROM THE
CONSENT CALENDAR AT THE REQUEST
OF THE AUTHOR FOR PURPOSES OF
AMENDMENTS CLERK WILL NOT.
THANK YOU. IN ORDER TO ROUTE.
BUT THANK YOU VERY MUCH. THE
VERY MUCH IS PRESENT TO PRESS
THE AUTHORS YOU CAN REMOVE THE
FOLLOWING FIVE ITEMS FROM THE
CONSENT CALENDAR. FILE ITEM TWO
FIFTY THREE WHICH IS AB FIFTY
EIGHT. FILE ITEM TWO FIFTY
SEVEN A. B. SIX OH NINE FILE
ITEM TO SIXTY FOUR AB EIGHT
SEVENTY FOUR. FILE ITEM TO
SIXTY SEVEN A. B. NINE FIFTY
SEVEN AND LASTLY FILE ITEM
NUMBER TWO SEVENTY ONE A. B.
THIRTEEN FIFTY FIVE THINKING IS
PRESENT. CLERK WILL NOTE SIR
PAN. THANK YOU MISTER PRESIDENT
PLEASE REMOVE FILE ITEM NUMBER
TWO SIXTY SIX EIGHTY EIGHT
NINETY NINE BY SUMMER WOOD FROM
THE CONSENT CALENDAR THANK YOU
THANK YOU. SENATOR NELSON.
PRESIDENT REQUEST AT THE AT THE
REQUEST OF THE AUTHOR TO REMOVE
FROM THE CONSENT CALENDAR FOR
PURPOSE OF AMENDMENT FILE ITEM
TWO FIVE FIVE AB TWO FIVE SIX
THIS WOULD BE FROM ASSEMBLY
MEMBER. I BY A CURRY THANK YOU.
CLERK WILL NOTE SENATOR
JACKSON'S. THANK YOU MISTER
PRESIDENT AT THE REQUEST OF THE
AUTHOR I WOULD LIKE TO REMOVE
FILE ITEM TO SEVENTY SEVEN AB
EIGHTEEN EIGHTEEN FROM THE
CONSENT CALENDAR FOR PURPOSES
OF AMENDMENT THANK YOU THE
CLERK WILL NOTE. SENATOR. I
COULD A GET JOHNNY IDENTITY
REMARKABLE OF I'M SORRY THREE
GALGIANI APOLOGIZE THANK YOU AT
THE REQUEST OF THE AUTHOR AND I
TO REMOVE FILE ITEM NUMBER TWO
SEVENTY FOUR A. B. SIXTEEN
THIRTY THREE. FROM THE CONSENT
CALENDAR FOR PURPOSES OF
AMENDMENTS THANK YOU THE CLERK
WILL NOTE. OKAY SENATOR MCGUIRE
THANK YOU SO MUCH AS PRESIDENT
AT THE REQUEST OF A SIMILAR
MAIENSCHEIN WOULD LIKE TO. MOVE
FILE NUMBER ONE ZERO SEVEN A.
B. ELEVEN TWENTY FOUR. TO THE
INACTIVE FILE. THANK YOU THE
CLERK WILL NOTE CENTER OFF.
THANK YOU WAS PRESENT AT THE
REQUEST OF THE AUTHOR'S REQUEST
OF THE FOLLOWING FILE ITEMS BE
REMOVED FROM THE CONSENT
CALENDAR ITEM TWO FIVE FOR A.
B. ONE SEVEN SIX. ITEM TWO
SEVEN THREE AB ONE FIFTEEN
EIGHTY EIGHT AND ITEM TWO SIX
FOUR. AB EIGHT SEVEN FOUR THE
CLERK WILL NOTE. STE SENATOR
DALLY. THERE WAS PRESIDENT A
REQUEST OF THE AUTHOR FILE ITEM
TO SIXTY ONE WALDRON AB EIGHT
AB SIX EIGHT SIX. REQUEST
REMOVAL FOR AMENDMENTS THE
CLERK WILL NOTE. AND THEREFORE
MOMENTS AT THE DESK THEY WILL
BE DEEMED ADOPTED. CENTER
WINNER I THANK YOU MISTER
PRESIDENT AKA AT THE REQUEST OF
THE AUTHOR PLEASE REMOVE PLEASE
MOVE FILE ITEM ONE SEVENTY
THREE AB FIVE SEVEN BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER AUG WE ARE. KERRY TO BE
AN ACTOR. ALSO AT THE REQUEST
OF THE AUTHOR PLEASE REMOVE
FILE ITEM TWO SEVENTY TWO AB
FOURTEEN SEVENTY THREE BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER GRAY FROM THE
CONSENT CALENDAR. CLERK WILL
NOT. CENTERED OUR PRESIDENT AYE
AYES RESPECT THAT BUILDING TO
BE MOVED TO THIRD READING NOT
AMENDMENTS THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
WHAT ARE JACKSON THE SENATE
JOURNAL FOR AUGUST TWELFTH
THROUGH THE FIFTEENTH TWO
THOUSAND NINETEEN WILL BE
APPROVED AS CORRECTED BY THE
MINUTE CLERK. YEAH. HERE.
MOVING ON TO THE CONSIDERATION
DAILY FILE ON THE SECOND
READING WE HAVE ITEMS ONE
THROUGH EIGHT. MISTER SECRETARY
PLEASE READ. ASSEMBLY BILL OF
FOURTEEN FORTY TWO WITH THE
MOMENTS. 1-013-497-4883 TWENTY
ONE ASSEMBLY BILL FIVE SEVENTY
SEVEN NINE FORTY SIX ASSEMBLY
BILL SIX OH FIVE. THANK YOU.
UNDER GOVERNOR'S APPOINTMENTS
THIRD AWOKE. BY ON ELEVEN AND
THIRTEEN YET THANK YOU MISTER
PRESIDENT MEMBERS SOUTH FILE
ITEM ELEVEN IS A CONFIRMATION
OF RICHARD BRAZIL TO THE
COMMISSION OF PEACE OFFICERS
STANDARDS AND TRAINING MR BURKE
BRAZIL HAS SERVED ON THE
COMMISSION SINCE TWO THOUSAND
AND FIFTEEN HE SPENT THIRTY
THREE YEARS WITH THE SACRAMENTO
POLICE DEPARTMENT INCLUDING
SERVING AS CHIEF OF POLICE FROM
TWO THOUSAND EIGHT THROUGH
TWENTY TWELVE. HE'S A FORMER
PRESIDENT OF THE CALIFORNIA
PEACE OFFICERS ASSOCIATION HE
WAS APPROVED BY RULES COMMITTEE
ON JULY THIRD ON UNANIMOUS VOTE
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE. SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. ALLEN HI ARCHULETA.
ATKINS BY BATES HI BILL. I
PORGES I BRADFORD I CAMBIADO I
TING HI DOLLY I DODD HI THERE
ALSO I GALGIANI I GLAZER I
GONZALEZ. GROWTH HI. HERTZBERG
BY HILL. HI WITH SO BY TITLE I
JACKSON BY JONES. LEYVA TIME
ACQUIRE I MITCHELL BY MORNING
I'M MORE LOCKED. MORALE NIELSEN
I PAN BY PORTANTINO ROTH I
RUBIO AYE SKINNER I STERN AYE
STONE NO NUMBER. IA CATHY I
WINNER BY WILK BY. SIX THREE
PLEASE CALL ABSENT MEMBERS
ARCHULETA GONZALEZ HI. JONES
MORE LOCK MORALE PORTANTINO.
PRICE THIRTY FOUR KNOWS ONE THE
APPOINTMENT IS CONFIRMED.
SENATE THIRD READING. FIVE ITEM.
ALL THIRTEEN I'M SORRY OKAY I'M
SO WHICH YEAH I THANK YOU
MISTER PRESIDENT MEMBERS FILE
ITEM NUMBER THIRTEEN IS A
CONFIRMATION OF DENNIS SOUTH
VERY TO THE HORSE RACING BOARD
MR OFF THE EYRIE IS THE
MANAGING MEMBER OF MISSION REAL
MISSION REAL ESTATE GROUP YES
PREP PREVIOUSLY SERVED ON THE
EARTHQUAKE AUTHORITY AS WELL AS
A LOS ANGELES COUNTY HOUSING
AUTHORITY BOARD HE WAS APPROVED
BY THE RULES COMMITTEE ON THE
TENTH OF JULY ON UNANIMOUS
VOTE. RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
AYE VOTE. IT IS SENATORS
HERTZBERG THANK YOU VERY MUCH
IS PRESENT I JUST WANT TO JOIN
IN STRONG SUPPORT OF THIS
APPOINTMENT I WORK WITH HIM AT
THE LOS ANGELES COUNTY ECONOMIC
DEVELOPMENT CORPORATION AND
BELL ISLAND OF THAT GREAT GROUP
AND HE IS GOOD PERSONAL DO A
GOOD JOB. ANY FURTHER
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THIS
APPOINTMENT. TURN ON MISTER
KERR PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. I
ARCHULETA ATKINS AYE BATES HI
BILL I PORGES. I BRADFORD ART
HI KELLY AT ALL I CHIANG HI
DOLLY I DODD HI DORADO I
GALGIANI I GLAZER. HI GONZALEZ
I GROWTH. HERTZBERG AYE HILL
AYE HUESO AYE OR TITLE. I
JACKSON AYE JONES I LEYVA. BY
MCGUIRE AYE MITCHELL AYE
MONNING I'M MORE LOCK I AM REAL
I NIELSEN HI PAN AYE PORTANTINO
ROTH AYE RUBIO. I SKINNER I
STERN I STONE I AM BURKE OUR
COUNTY I WINNER HI WILK HI.
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS
ARCHULETA GROWTH. BY PORTANTINO.
ICE THIRTY EIGHT NO ZERO THE
APPOINTMENT IS CONFIRMED. MOVIE
BACK JOHN FINISH BUSINESS. WE
HAVE FILE ITEM FIFTEEN. CENTER
CHANNEL YOU PREPARE FOR THIS
ITEM. INSTRUCTOR PLEASE ROUTE
SENATE BILL TWO FORTY FIVE A
SENATOR CHIANG AN ACT RELATING
TO PUBLIC ANIMAL SHELTERS INNER
TURN THANK YOU MISTER PRESIDENT
MEMBERS SB TWO FORTY FIVE KNOWN
AS THE PETS FOR BUT AT ACT HAS
COME BACK TO THE SENATE AFTER
PASSING THE ASSEMBLY FLOOR WITH
A VOTE OF SEVENTY SIX ZERO.
THIS BILL WOULD WAIVE ADOPTION
FEES AT LOCAL PUBLIC ANIMAL
SHELTERS FOR MILITARY VETERANS
MANY OF WHOM SEEK EMOTIONAL
SUPPORT ANIMAL COMPANIONS WHO
THE PUBLIC SHELTER SYSTEM THIS
BILL THE SMALL BUT IMPACTFUL
STEP IN SHOWING OUR
APPRECIATION FOR VETERANS AND
HELPING THOSE WHO STRUGGLE WITH
PTSD. I RESPECTFULLY REQUEST AN
AYE VOTE. ANY FURTHER
DISCUSSION DEBATE ON THIS ITEM
SEEING HEARING ON THE SECTOR
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. ALLEN I
ARCHULETA ATKINS I BATES. I
BILL BY BRIDGES HI BRADFORD I
CARRY IT ALL I CHIANG I DALY
AYE DODD BY THE RAZA I GALGIANI
I GLAZER. I GONZALEZ BY GROVE.
HI HERTZBERG. I HILL AYE HUESO
AYE HER TITLE I JACKSON I JONES.
I LEYVA AYE MCGUIRE AYE
MITCHELL. MITCHELL HI MONEY.
I'M MORE LOCK I'M A REAL I
NIELSEN. I PAN AYE PORTANTINO.
ROTH AYE RUBIO AYE SKINNER AYE
STERN AYE STONE AYE AMBERG I
WOULD COUNTY. WIENER BY WILK BY.
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS
ARCHULETA PORTANTINO WORK OUT
SEE. OURS THIRTY SEVEN NO ZERO
THE MEASURE PASSES. ALL I'M
SORRY SYNONYMS ARE CONCURRED IN.
OUR NEXT UP IS ITEM OF FILE
ITEM TWENTY THREES SENATOR
MONEY ARE YOU PREPARED FOR THIS
ITEM YES MISS SECTOR PLEASE
READ. SENATE BILL SIX FORTY
FIVE A SENATOR MONNING AN ACT
RELATING TO DEPOSITIONS THE
MINING. THANK YOU MISTER
PRESIDENT MEMBERS AMENDMENTS
TAKEN TO SENATE BILL SIX FORTY
FIVE HAVE REMOVED OPPOSITION BY
GIVING FLEXIBILITY TO THE TOTAL
HOUR LIMIT FOR DEPOSITIONS
RELATED TO MESOTHELIOMA IN
SILICOSIS CASES. THIS BILL WILL
ASSURE THAT VICTIMS ARE TREATED
HUMANELY IN THE CIVIL JUSTICE
SYSTEM DURING THE LAST WEEKS OF
THEIR LIVES I ASKED FOR
CONCURRENCE WITH ASSEMBLY
AMENDMENTS THANK YOU. ANY
FURTHER DISCUSSION DEBATE ON
THIS ITEM SINGING HEARING ON
INSTRUCTOR PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
ALLEN. I ARCHULETA ATKINS. AYE
BATES AYE BILL I BRIDGES HI
BRADFORD I CAMBIADO I TING AYE
DALY BY DODD. BY THE RUSSELL
AYE GALGIANI AYE GLAZER I
GONZALEZ I GROWTH. I HERTZBERG
AYE HILL AYE HUESO BY TACO I
JACKSON I JONES. LEYVA AYE
MCGUIRE AYE MITCHELL BY MORNING
I'M MORE LOCK. I'M REAL.
NIELSEN. I PAN AYE PORTANTINO
ROUGH AYE RUBIO AYE SKINNER. I
STERN AYE STONE HI NUMBER
BARBARA COUNTY AYE WIENER AYE
WILK HI. SURGERY PLEASE CALL
THE ABSENT MEMBERS ARCHULETA
JONES. HI MORRELL. PORTANTINO.
ALL EYES THIRTY FOUR NO ZERO
THOSE FAMILY MOMENTS. THIRTY
SEVEN I'M SORRY OZ THIRTY SEVEN
NO ZERO THE SIMI MEMBERS ARE
CONCORD. MOVING ON NOW TO
SENATE THIRD READING AND WE
HAVE FILE ITEM TWENTY NINE.
THAT MEMORY TAKE THAT ITEM UP.
CENTER CHANNEL PREPARED.
SECRETARY PLEASE READ SENATE
RESOLUTION FOURTEEN BY SENATOR
CHIANG RELATIVE TO KOREAN
INDEPENDENCE DAY SOONER CHIANG
THANK YOU MISTER PRESIDENT TO
CALL THE CITY I RISE TO PRESENT
SENATE RESOLUTION FOURTEEN
RECOGNIZING AUGUST FIFTEENTH
TWENTY NINETEEN AS THE SEVENTY
FOURTH ANNIVERSARY OF THE
INDEPENDENCE OF THE REPUBLIC OF
KOREA KOREAN INDEPENDENCE DAY
COMMEMORATES THE LIBERATION OF
KOREA FROM JAPANESE
COLONIZATION HONORS THE LIVES
OF MEMORIES OF THE THOUSANDS OF
BRAVE KOREANS WHO FOUGHT FOR
THE FREEDOM. ACOSTA WORLD
KOREANS YOU UNITE TO REMEMBER
THEIR INDEPENDENCE DAY AND
CELEBRATE THEIR RICH CULTURE
AND HERITAGE CALIFORNIA IS HOME
TO MORE THAN FOUR HUNDRED AND
FIFTY FIVE THOUSAND GREEN
AMERICANS TO CELEBRATE THIS
IMPORTANT HOLIDAY OUR STATE AND
OUR COUNTRY HAS BEEN ENRICHED
BY THE CONTRIBUTIONS OF KOREAN
AMERICANS IN THE FIELDS OF
BUSINESS SPORTS ARTS AND
ENTERTAINMENT. CIVICS AND
MILITARY. CONNECTING THE
IMPORTANCE OF THIS HOLIDAY
SEASON IS AN OPPORTUNITY TO
CELEBRATE GREEN HERITAGE AND
THE GREEN AMERICAN COMMUNITIES
CONTRIBUTION TO THE UNITED
STATES. I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
AYE VOTE THANK YOU. SENATOR
GIRL THANK YOU M. MISTER
PRESIDENT I TO RISE IN SUPPORT
OF SENATE RESOLUTION FOURTEEN
TODAY IS A SPECIAL DAY BECAUSE
IT MARKS THE SEVENTY FOURTH
ANNIVERSARY OF THE GREEN
INDEPENDENCE DAY ALSO KNOWN AS
NATIONAL LIBERATION DAY OF
KOREA THE HOLIDAY IS CELEBRATED
EVERY YEAR ON AUGUST FIFTEENTH
AS MY COLLEAGUE SAID IN BOTH
THE NORTH AND SOUTH KOREA ALL
COME TOGETHER AND COMMEMORATE
THEIR VICTORY OVER JAPAN AND
IT'S KNOWN AS JAPAN DAY OR
VICTORY OVER JAPAN DAY. IT'S
NOTABLE FOR BEING ONE THE
KOREAN PUBLIC HOLIDAY
CELEBRATED BY BOTH NORTH AND
SOUTH KOREA AND CALIFORNIA
CREATE AMERICANS ARE PROUD
BUSINESS OWNERS EDUCATORS
ENTREPRENEURS AND THEY'VE
INFLUENCE CALIFORNIA'S CULTURE
SOCIAL AND ECONOMIC LANDSCAPE
FOR THESE REASONS AND MANY MORE
I JOIN IN AND SUPPORTING AS OUR
FOURTEEN. THANK YOU SENATOR
ALSO. YES I TO RISE IN SUPPORT
OF THIS. BILL AND I'D LIKE TO
ADD THAT SENATE MY SEAT MATE
CENTER HOLLY MITCHELL AND I
WERE PLEASED TO SUPPORT THE
FUNDING FOR THE KOREAN AMERICAN
MUSEUM IT WILL BE THE FIRST AND
ONLY KOREAN AMERICAN MUSEUM
OUTSIDE OF KOREA. OF THIS IS A
VERY VERY IMPORTANT A STEP IT
WILL BE THE ONLY ONE IN THE
COUNTRY. AND I THINK THAT THE
BEST WAY OF NOT ONLY REMEMBER
IN HERE IN THE LEGISLATURE BUT
ALSO ESTABLISHING A PERMANENT
PLACE. FOR US ALL TO
ACKNOWLEDGE LEARN AND
UNDERSTAND THE ENORMOUS
CONTRIBUTIONS OF THE KOREAN THE
KOREAN AMERICAN COMMUNITY SO I
ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE. THANK YOU
SENATOR PAN. THANK YOU MISTER
PRESIDENT SENATORS I TO RISE IN
SUPPORT OF SR FOURTEEN AND US
VICE CHAIR OF THE FEI
LEGISLATIVE CAUCUSES I WANT TO
I THINK MIKE A GOOD FRIEND FROM
DIAMOND BAR FOR BRING THIS
RESOLUTION FORD I WOULD ALSO
MAKE NOTE THAT IN ADDITION TO
THEIR WONDERFUL CONTRIBUTIONS
THAT MANY OF THE FIELDS ARE
PREVIOUSLY REFERENCED BY MY
GOOD. I COLLEAGUES HERE THEY
HAVE ALSO BEEN SIGNIFICANT
ABUSES OF THE FIELD OF MEDICINE
THE ONE I'M IN AS WELL AND I'VE
JUST ALSO WANT TO SAY THAT THIS
IS A- TODAY IS A TREMENDOUS
OPPORTUNITY TO RECORD. HIGHS
THE- GREAT CONTRIBUTIONS OF
KOREAN AMERICANS TO OUR
COUNTRY. THEY HAVE GIVEN SO
MUCH. AS MANY OF THEM HAD COME
HERE AFTER. OUR INVOLVEMENT IN
THE COUNTRY AS WELL SO WITH
TODAY'S OF WONDERFUL DAY OF
CELEBRATION AND I HOPE THAT AS
WE GO HOME TODAY AFTER SESSION
THAT WE WILL. SEEK
OPPORTUNITIES TO ENGAGE WITH
OUR- CLEAN AMERICAN
CONSTITUENTS. I URGE AN AYE
VOTE ON THE RESOLUTION THANK
YOU. THANK YOU SEE NO FOR THE
DESCRIPTION DEBATE SYNERGEN
WHICH OUGHT TO CLOSE. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE THANK THANK YOU THE SECTOR
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. ALLEN ALL
OF THE I'M SORRY S
ELIGIBLE FOR UNANIMOUS ROLL
CALLS ANY OBJECTION FOR USING A
YOU NAM STROKE ALL. NO
OBJECTION OUR THIRTY EIGHT EYES
NO ZERO THE MEASURE PASSAGE.
YEAH. EMILY THIRD READING FIRST
ITEM UP IS ITEM FORTY FOUR. ARE
YOU. AUTHOR COPY ARE YOU
PREPARED FOR THIS ITEM
INSTRUCTOR PLEASE READ.
ASSEMBLY JOINT RESOLUTION
ELEVEN BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
CARILLO RELATIVE TO IMMIGRATION.
CENTER COPIER. THANK YOU MISTER
PRESIDENT FOR THE OPPORTUNITY
TO PRESENT AJ ARE ELEVEN ON
BEHALF OF ASSEMBLY MEMBER
CARDIO. WHICH URGES THE
PRESIDENT AND THE UNITED STATES
CONGRESS TO PASS THE
DEVELOPMENT RELIEF AND
EDUCATION FOR ALIEN MINERS ALSO
KNOWN AS DREAM ACT TO PROVIDE A
PERMANENT SOLUTION FOR
IMMIGRANT YOUTH AND THOSE
PROTECTED UNDER TEMPORARY
PROTECTED STATUS DE PS AND
DEFERRED ENFORCED DEPARTURE THE
E. D. AJ. ARE ELEVEN ALSO
SUPPORTS HOUSE RESOLUTION
NUMBER SIX WHICH REINTRODUCES
THE DREAM BACK WITH PROTECTIONS
FOR TPS AND DEFERRED ENFORCED
DEPARTURE RECIPIENTS SINCE ITS
ORIGINAL INTRODUCTION IN TWO
THOUSAND ONE THE DREAM ACT
PROVIDES A MULTI PHASE PROCESS
FOR QUALIFYING A DOCUMENT
UNDOCUMENTED IMMIGRANT YOUTH TO
SEEK RESIDENCY AND A PATH TO
CITIZENSHIP. OVER THE YEARS THE
DREAM ACT AS HAS BEEN
CONTINUOUSLY BAITED HOWEVER
CONGRESS HAS BEEN UNWILLING TO
TAKE ACTION. A STATE COURTS
CONTINUE TO RULE ON BOTH THE
DOCTOR TPS AND DVD PROGRAMS IT
IS CRUCIAL THAT CONGRESS CREATE
A PERMANENT SOLUTION FOR OUR
FRIENDS. FAMILY AND NEIGHBORS
TOUCH BY BOTH PROGRAMS
CALIFORNIA HAS THE HIGHEST
NUMBER OF IMMIGRANTS SUBJECT TO
THESE PROGRAMS WHICH ALL
REQUIRE GAINFUL EMPLOYMENT AND
GOOD CONDUCT TO PARTICIPATE. IT
IS IMPERATIVE THAT WE URGE
FEDERAL ACTION NOW AS THE
UNITED STATES SUPREME COURT
PREPARES TO HEAR ARGUMENTS ON
DHAKA IN THE NEXT FEW MONTHS
AND IF I COULD SAY YOU KNOW
WE'VE ALL HEARD. THE CALIFORNIA
HAS A LACK OF INDIVIDUALS READY
TO WORK THE HAVE BA DEGREES.
AND IF THERE'S EVER AN INSTANCE
WHERE WE COULD IMMEDIATELY MAKE.
YOUNG PEOPLE WHO HAVE BEEN
EDUCATED HAVE GROWN UP IN OUR
STATE AND HAVE ON REALLY DONE
EVERYTHING NECESSARY. THEY'VE
LIVED A GOOD CLEAN LIFE AND
THEY'RE READY TO TAKE THEIR
PLACE IN OUR SOCIETY NOW IS THE
TIME TO DO IT. AS A SIDE NOTE
TODAY AUGUST FIFTEENTH. IS THE
FIRST DAY PEOPLE WERE ABLE TO
APPLY FOR THE DOC A- PROGRAM SO
IT'S THE SEVENTH ANNIVERSARY OF
THE DOCTOR DOCTOR
IMPLEMENTATION DATE AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE ON THIS IMPORTANT MEASURE.
THANK YOU CENTER CABALLERO
DISCUSSION AND DEBATE CENTER
HUESO. I RISE IN SUPPORT OF HR
ELEVEN MADAM PRESIDENT AND
SIMPLY URGE EVERYONE HERE TO
SUPPORT THIS YOU KNOW WE ARE
SINCE I ARRIVED HERE IN THE
LEGISLATURE WE'VE BEEN TALKING
ABOUT IMMIGRATION REFORM. AND
CREATING A MEANINGFUL PATHWAY
TO CITIZENSHIP IN OUR COUNTRY.
IT'S BEEN A DEBATE THAT I THINK
HAS BEEN. OF DISCUSSED EVERY
SINGLE HERE YEAR HERE ON THIS
FLOOR AND IN THE LEGISLATURE
YET. AS WE HAVE SENT SOLUTIONS
TO WASHINGTON OF WHAT A
IMMIGRATION REFORM IS THERE HAS
A FAILURE TO ACT WE ONLY GET
RHETORIC FROM WASHINGTON AND
CURRENTLY. WE ARE SEEING SOME
VERY AGGRESSIVE MEASURES BEING
UNDERTAKEN BY THIS CURRENT
ADMINISTRATION. ODD. MEASURES
THAT ARE HURTING OUR STATE'S
ECONOMY WE'RE GETTING STORIES
NOW OF FARMERS PLOWING THEIR
FIELDS BECAUSE THEY CAN'T FIND
LABOR THERE'S A LABOR SHORTAGE
NOT ONLY IN CALIFORNIA BUT IN
THE COUNTRY. AGRICULTURAL
INDUSTRY IN MY DISTRICT IS VERY
BIG IT'S VERY IMPORTANT BUT
IT'S ALSO VERY IMPORTANT TO THE
STATE. ON THE WAY THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT THE FIND SKILLED
LABOR. IS IN A WAY THAT DOES
NOT RECOGNIZE THAT FARMWORKERS
ARE SKILLED LABOR OF THE OF THE
FARM FARMERS YES A VERY
IMPORTANT BUT THE FARMWORKERS
ARE IS WELL. WHAT THEY DO
REQUIRES AN ENORMOUS AMOUNT OF
SKILL AND YEARS AND YEARS OF
PRACTICE TO LEARN THEY ARE
SKILLED LABOR SOONEST GONNA
HAVE. AN ENORMOUS IMPACT OUR
ECONOMY THIS IS SOMETHING THIS
LEGISLATURE NEEDS TO FIGHT FOR
WE NEED TO FIGHT FOR OUR
ECONOMY WE NEED TO FIGHT FOR
THE FARMERS THAT ARE HAVING A
HARD TIME FINDING LABOR WE NEED
TO FIGHT. FOR OTHERS WORKERS AS
WELL. THAT ARE HERE TO PROVIDE
A BENEFIT TO OUR STATE. AND WE
IN TURN THEM SOMETHING IN
RETURN SO THIS IS A VERY
IMPORTANT MATTER IT'S STARTING
TO HAVE SERIOUS IMPACTS ON OUR
STATE AND OUR COUNTRY'S ECONOMY.
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN. YOU KNOW
THERE THERE IS A VERY QUIET. A
SCREAM COMING FROM OUR
AGRICULTURAL AREAS ESPECIALLY
FROM OUR FARMERS ARE NOW
STARTING TO TAKE AGGRESSIVE
ACTIONS TO KEEP THEIR
BUSINESSES A FLOAT. AND SO. THE
YOU KNOW IT'S GOTTEN TO THE
POINT WHERE THERE IS NO. NO
IMMIGRATION REFORM BEING
CONSIDERED IN WASHINGTON WHAT
QUITE THE OPPOSITE VERY
AGGRESSIVE EFFORTS ARE BEING
TAKEN ACROSS THE COUNTRY TO
DENY CITIZENSHIP TO THE
CHILDREN OF IMMIGRANTS BORN IN
THE UNITED STATES AND TO
SEPARATE THEIR FAMILIES THROUGH
VERY AGGRESSIVE. OF DEPORTATION
POLICIES THEY'RE VIOLATING
THESE INDIVIDUALS RIGHTS SO I
WOULD HOPE THAT IN THE
INTERESTS OF OUR STATE IN OUR
STATE'S ECONOMY AND THE WELL
BEING OF THE PEOPLE OF OUR
STATE. AND THE AND THIS FABRIC
OF OUR SOCIETY IT'S BETWEEN A
PART TORN APART THAT WE ALL
STAND TOGETHER WITH THE LEAD AS
A LEGISLATURE AND SENT A VERY
STRONG MESSAGE TO WASHINGTON.
THAT WE ARE VERY CONCERNED
ABOUT NOT ONLY THE FUTURE OF
OUR STATE BUT THE FUTURE OF OUR
COUNTRY THANK YOU MAN PRESENT.
THANK YOU SENATOR HUESO SENATOR
PAN. YOU MAY I PRESENT CENTERS
I TO STAND IN SUPPORT OF THIS
RESOLUTION I WOULD IF YOU WANT
TO MAKE NOTE THAT OF. IN THE
API COMMUNITY HERE IN
CALIFORNIA. OVER HALF ARE
IMMIGRANTS. AND THERE ARE MANY
WHO HAVE BEEN BROUGHT AS
CHILDREN AND MAY NOT BE
DOCUMENTED SO THIS IS AN ISSUE
THAT AFFECTS ALL OF CALIFORNIA.
AND THIS IS A VERY IMPORTANT
RESOLUTION TO ENSURE THAT OUR
STATE IN OUR COUNTRY. THE TEARS
TO THE VALUES THAT WE. ALWAYS
HELD IN THIS COUNTRY IN TERMS
OF WELCOMING IMMIGRANTS AND
INVESTING IN THE FUTURE OF OUR
COUNTRY AND AGAIN WHAT I THINK
THE AUTHOR FOR BRING SOARED.
THANK YOU CENTER PAN SEE NO
FURTHER DISCUSSION OR DEBATE
THE RECALL WHERE WOULD YOU LIKE
TO CLOSE. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
FOR THE COMMENTS THAT WERE MADE
HERE TODAY YOU KNOW THE TPS
PROGRAM REALLY FOCUSES ON
COUNTRIES WHERE THERE'S A CIVIL
UNREST IN WHERE THE VIOLENCE
AND THE- THE TERRORISM THAT IS
ON GOING IS SO YOU SO DRAMATIC
THAT PEOPLE ARE ARE. ARE
FLEEING IN COMING TO OUR
COUNTRY AND THAT PROGRAM IS
INVOLVED IN A NUMBER OF
DIFFERENT ETHNIC GROUPS AND SO
IT'S REALLY IMPORTANT THAT WE
RECOGNIZE THAT WE'RE WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT PEOPLE WHO HAVE
GREAT CONTRIBUTIONS TO MAKE TO
OUR COUNTRY AND THAT IT'S
IMPERATIVE THAT CONGRESS ACT. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE THE USER CABALLERO MISTER
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALLEN I ARCHULETA ATKINS AYE
BATES. BELL HI FORGES. BRADFORD
I CAL YELLOW. I CHIANG BY DALY
DOT BY THE RAZA I GOT JOHNNY I
GLAZER I GONZALEZ HI GROW.
HERTZBERG AYE HILL AYE HUESO
AYE OR TITLE I JACKSON AYE
JONES. LEYVA AYE MCGUIRE AYE
MITCHELL HI MONEY BY MORE LOCK
MORALE NIELSEN IN. BY
PORTANTINO ROTH I RUBIO I
SKINNER BY STERN AYE STONE.
NUMBER TYLER CASKEY I WINNER BY
WILK HI. THIS CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS ARCHULETA BATES.
BURGESS DALY. GROVE JONES MORE
LOCK MORRELL NIELSEN PORTANTINO
STONE. PRICE TWENTY NINE OH
ZERO THE RESOLUTION IS ADOPTED
MEMBERS WE ARE GOING TO GO BACK
TO MOTIONS AND RESOLUTIONS
SENATOR BRADFORD. THANK YOU
MADAM PRESIDENT AT THE
REQUESTED AUTHOR I'M GONNA
HOUSE FOR IT AB FIFTEEN EIGHTY
EIGHT TO BE REMOVED ITEM TO
SEVENTY THREE AT THE FROM THE
CONSENT CALENDAR THANK YOU
CENTER BRADFORD THE DESK WILL
NOTE MEMBERS WE ARE NOW MOVING
TO FILE ITEM ONE OH FOUR
SENATOR BRADFORD. MISTER
SECRETARY PLEASE READ. ASSEMBLY
BILL EIGHT TWENTY NINE BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER BLOOM AND THAT
CLING TO PUBLIC POST SECONDARY
EDUCATION. CENTER BRADFORD
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT. AB
EIGHT TO NINE WOULD ALLOW SEE
ISSUES TO AWARD DOCTOR TO
GREASE AN OCCUPATIONAL THERAPY
TO ENSURE THE CONTINUATION OF
HIGH DEMAND HIGH NEED PROGRAMS
AT OUR CO SHOOT CAPTAINS
CAMPUSES. OCCUPATIONAL
THERAPY'S R. O. T. SUPPORT
CHILDREN WITH LEARNING
DISABILITIES PEOPLE RECOVERING
FROM INJURIES AN OLDER ADULTS
EXPERIENCING. CON A COGNITIVE
AND PHYSICAL CHANGES AS WITH
MANY HEALTHCARE PROFESSIONS
CALIFORNIA HAS A SHORTAGE OF
TEAS AND RANKS FORTY FOURTH IN
THE NATION IN ACCESS STOCK
PROVISIONAL THERAPIST.
CURRENTLY SEVENTY SIX OF THE
NINETY SIX OCCUPATIONAL THERAPY
PROGRAM UP MASTER PROGRAMS IN
THE COUNTRY ARE TRANSITIONING
TO A DOCTOR'S DEGREE INCLUDING
ALL OF OUR CALIFORNIA PRIVATE
PROGRAMS. AB EIGHT TO NINE
WOULD PROVIDE CALIFORNIANS WHAT
THE AFFORDABLE OPTION OF
PURSUING A CAREER AND
OCCUPATIONAL THERAPY WE PUT.
WITH THE PROJECTED GROWTH IN
EMPLOYMENT OF 24% OUR ABILITY
TO OFFER THESE PROGRAMS WHICH
GREATLY IMPACT TO SUPPLY OF
HIGHLY SOUGHT AFTER HEALTH CARE
SPECIALIST THIS ITEM HAS NO
OPPOSITION I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR AYE VOTE. THANK YOU
CENTER BRADFORD CENTER NIELSEN
THE PRESIDENT LAID DOWN THE
SENATE I RISE IN SUPPORT OF
THIS BUT WITH A QUESTION. HE
DOCTORAL EDUCATION UNDER THE
MASTER PLAN OF HIGHER EDUCATION
IS THE PURVIEW OF YOU SEE. AND
THAT WAS CLEARLY DEFINED IN THE
SIXTIES ORIGINAL MASTER PLAN.
WAS PUT INTO EFFECT IT'S WORKED
VERY WELL BUT OVER THE DECADES
IT'S BECOME CLEAR THAT THERE
ARE CERTAIN DISCIPLINE AREAS
WHERE I BELIEVE. AND OTHERS
HAVE TO THAT A DOCTORAL
EDUCATION AT THE CSU LEVEL
WOULD BE APPROPRIATE NURSING
WAS ONE EXAMPLE THIS IS ANOTHER
ONE DOLLAR THOUGH URGING AN AYE
VOTE AS WE PROCEED I WOULD SAY
THAT WE SHOULD WAX CAUTIOUS
ABOUT HOW MANY OF THESE DOCTOR
OPPORTUNITIES WE PROVIDE. TO
YOU SEE I MEAN TO ME YOU SEE TO
DO THE DOCTORAL AT CSU JUST TO
BE CONSISTENT WITH THE MASTER
PLAN AND NOT DILUTE THE
PROGRAMS. ON THIS ONE I WOULD
TONIGHT WILL. THANK YOU CENTER
NIELSEN FOR THE DISCUSSION AND
DEBATE CENTER PAN. THANK YOU
MADAM PRESIDENT SENATORS. I TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF THIS BELL
BUT I ALSO APPRECIATE THAT THE
COMMENTS MY GOOD FRIEND FROM TO
HIM CERTAINLY INTO MIDI. I HAVE
RAISED ON THIS BILL AND SOME
OTHER BILLS AS WELL THAT
UNFORTUNATELY ACTUALLY ARE
HIGHER EDUCATION PROGRAMS AT C.
S. U. IN SOME EASIER
COMMUNICABLE AGES. OUR
CHALLENGE TO BECAUSE SOME OF
THE- PROFESSIONAL SOCIETIES FOR
VARIOUS OCCUPATIONS. HAVE TRIED
TO INCREASE THE CREDENTIALS AND
THEREFORE REQUIRED HIGHER
CREDENTIALS FOR PEOPLE TO BE
ABLE TO PRACTICE IN THAT
PARTICULAR OCCUPATION. AND THIS
UNFORTUNATELY IS. PUTTING OUR
HIGHER EDUCATION SYSTEM IN A
BIND SO WHAT WE'LL TALK ABOUT
THE VISION THERAPY IDEOLOGY OR
SOME OTHERS AND WELL IT'S A
LITTLE CHALLENGING FOR US
BECAUSE WE DON'T. OVERSEE THOSE
OCCUPATIONS WE OVERSEE
LICENSING WE OVERSEE OUR
EDUCATIONAL PROGRAMS I THINK
THERE IS A- PERHAPS
CONVERSATION WE THAT NEEDS TO
BE HAD IN OUR SOCIETY ABOUT.
THE PRICE OF INCREASING THOSE
CREDENTIALS THIS IS ONLY ONE
SOMETHING THE OTHER PROBLEM IS
OF COURSE WE TALK ABOUT STUDENT
DEBT AND HOW MANY YEARS YOU
NEED TO BE IN SCHOOL AND SO
FORTH AS WELL. SO AGAIN I
SUPPORT THIS BILL. BUT I ALSO
FEEL THAT THERE THIS IS A
THERE'S A LARGER ISSUE AROUND
THIS THAT NEEDS ALSO BE ADDRESS
MUSIC AFFECTS A WORK FORCE THAT
AFFECTS THE COST OF CERTAIN
SERVICES AND CERTAINLY AS YOU
CAN SEE AND THE FACT THAT WE
HAVE TO DO THIS BILL THAT I'M
SUPPORTING TODAY. THAT THAT
ALSO IS AFFECTING OUR HIGHER
EDUCATION SYSTEM AS WELL THANK
YOU. THANK YOU CENTER PANCER
GALGIANI. I RISE TO SUPPORT
THIS BILL BUT I ECHO MY
COLLEAGUES COMMENTS I USED TO
WORK AS A PHYSICAL THERAPY
AIDE. AT OUR COUNTY HOSPITAL
BEFORE. THE PROGRAM WAS.
VIRTUALLY IN BANKRUPTCY AND WE
HAD TO DO AWAY WITH THE
PROGRAM. BUT IF I WANTED TO GO
BACK TO WORK AS A PHYSICAL
THERAPY AIDE TODAY. THAT
LARGELY IS WITHOUT WHICH WAS
NOT IN REACH ANYMORE BECAUSE OF
THE EDUCATIONAL REQUIREMENTS
THAT WE KEEP. IMPOSING IN THESE
PROFESSIONS. WHY SUPPORT HIRING
EDUCATION I ALSO RECOGNIZE THAT
WE HAVE TO FIND A BALANCE IF WE
HAVE A SHORTAGE IN THESE
PROFESSIONS WE HAVE TO HAVE
PATHWAYS. FOR OTHERS FOR AIDS
FOR A TECHNOLOGISTS FOR
ASSISTANCE TO BE ABLE TO COME
IN AND FOLLOW AND WORK WITH
THEM SO THAT WE ARE ABLE TO
PROVIDE THE CARE THAT'S NEEDED
WE KNOW THAT WE HAVE SHORTAGES
AND MOST OF OUR MEDICAL FIELD.
YET WE'RE NOT CREATING THE
POSITIONS FOR THOSE WHO ARE
ASSISTING THOSE WHO HAVE THESE
MASTERS DEGREES AND DOCTORS
DEGREES THANK YOU. THE USER
GALGIANI MEMBERS ANY FURTHER
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE SEEING AND
HEARING NONE. IS THERE ANY
OBJECTION TO USING UNANIMOUS
ROLL CALL. SEEING AND HEARING
NONE EYES THIRTY EIGHT NO ZERO
THE MEASURE PASSES MEMBERS
REMOVING THE FILE ITEM ONE OH
SIX SENATOR HER TADO. MISTER
SECRETARY PLEASE READ ASSEMBLY
BILL SEVEN THIRTY SEVEN BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER EGGMAN AN ACT
RELATING TO HEALTH FACILITIES.
SENATOR HURTADO. THANK YOU
MADAM PRESIDENT I RISE. AB
SEVEN THIRTY SEVEN WHICH IS A
CLEAN A BILL TO A. B. SIX ZERO
ONE WHICH WAS CHAPTER IN TWENTY
FIFTEEN UNDER EXISTING LAW THE
USE OF LIMITED LIABILITY
COMPANIES ENABLES OWNERS OF
RESIDENTIAL CARE FACILITIES FOR
THE ELDERLY TO OBSCURE THEIR
IDENTITIES THIS CONFUSES
FAMILIES WHO ARE SELECTING CARE
FOR THEIR LOVED ONES AND MAKING
STATE AGENCY RECORD KEEPING
UNCLEAR AND INCOMPLETE. AS A
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF SOCIAL
SERVICES IS THE ENTITY TASKED
WITH OUR CFE LICENSE OVERSIGHT
THIS BILL INCREASES
TRANSPARENCY OF THE RESIDENTIAL
CARE FACILITY FACILITIES
OWNERSHIP. THIS BILL GIVES THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF SOCIAL
SERVICES THE AUTHORITY TO ASK
FOR MORE INFORMATION PERTAINING
TO A LICENSE APPLICATION TO
DETERMINE WHO THE OWNER OF THE
FACILITY IS CLARITY OF
OWNERSHIP WILL HELP FAMILIES
MAKE WELL INFORMED DECISIONS
ABOUT THEIR LOVED ONES CARE BY
MAKING SURE RESIDENTIAL CARE
FACILITIES HAVE CLEAR OWNERSHIP
DATA AVAILABLE TO THEM. THIS
BILL HAS INTERNAL OPPOSITION.
AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR NAY
VOTE. JEAN NO DISCUSSION DEBATE
ON THIS ITEM IS THERE ANY
OBJECTION ABUSING A UNANIMOUS
ROLL CALL. THREE NINE AYE AYES
THIRTY EIGHT NO ZERO MEASURE
PASSES MOVING ON TO ITEM ONE
THIRTEEN. SENATOR NELSON. MR
KERRY PLEASE READ SENATE
CONCURRENT RESOLUTION EIGHTY
NINE BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER COOLEY
RELATIVE TO SPECIAL DISTRICTS
WEEK SENATOR NELSON THIS
PRESENT LADIES AND GENTLEMEN
THE SENATE SPECIAL DISTRICTS
HAVE PLAYED A VITAL ROLE IN THE
GROWTH IN THE PROSPERITY OF OUR
WONDERFUL STATE. I RISE TO
PRESENT TO YOU ACR EIGHTY NINE
DESIGNATING SEPTEMBER TWENTY
SECOND TO TWENTY EIGHT OF THIS
YEAR AS SPECIAL DISTRICTS WEEK.
THEY WERE FOUNDED IN FORMED. TO
ENSURE THAT LOCAL CITIZENS.
COULD HAVE SAY AND AFFECT.
SERVICES POLICIES AND
INFRASTRUCTURE. THEY TAKE MANY
FORMS THE SPECIAL DISTRICTS.
FOR EXAMPLE THE CREATION IN THE
LATE TWENTIETH CENTURY OF THESE
MOSQUITO ABATEMENT DISTRICTS
WHICH USED TO BE SUCH AN
AFFLICTION NASA DOT ON ON JUST
PERSONAL CONVENIENCE BEING OUT
AND ABOUT. BUT THE TRANSMISSION.
OF DISEASE WEST NILE VIRUS.
THERE ABOUT TWO THOUSAND OF
THESE SPECIAL DISTRICTS
THROUGHOUT THE STATE NOW
PROVIDING ESSENTIAL SERVICES.
ENSURING LOCAL CONTROL. AND
THAT RELATES TO ALL AREAS VITAL
TO US WATER FIRE SERVICES PARKS
RECREATION PORCH EVEN. AND OUR
HARBORS FLOOD CONTROL IS A VERY
BIG ROLE FOR OUR SPECIAL
DISTRICTS. THEY HELP FACILITATE
THE WORKING FUNCTIONING SAVE
CALIFORNIA. I WOULD REQUEST YOU
ARRIVE VOTE TO ACKNOWLEDGE OUR
SPECIAL DISTRICTS. THANK YOU
CENTER NELSON ANY FURTHER
DISCUSSION DEBATE ON THIS ITEM
SENIORNET THIS IS ELIGIBLE FOR
UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL VOTE IS
THERE ANY OBJECTION TO THE CITY.
SENATOR Y. KASKI OBJECTS. MISS
SECTOR PLEASE CALL THE ROLL ON
THE SIDE ALLEN. ARCHULETA
ATKINS HI BATES BY BILL. I
PURCHASED BY BREVARD I CAMBIADO
I CHIANG I DALY I DODD. THERE
ARE ALSO HI GALGIANI. BY GLAZER
I GONZALEZ. BY GROWTH I
HERTZBERG AYE HILL AYE HUESO
AYE HER TITLE BY JACKSON. I
JONES. I LEYVA AYE MCGUIRE AYE
MITCHELL. BY MONEY. MORE LUCK
I'M A REAL. I NIELSEN. I PAN
AYE PORTANTINO ROTH I RUBIO AYE
SKINNER AYE STERN AYE STONE. I
AM BURKE OUR COUNTY NO WIENER
AYE WILK BY. THE SECTOR PLEASE
CALL OUT TO MEMBERS ALLEN. HI
ARCHULETA DODD BY MORNING
PORTANTINO. ICE THIRTY SIX
KNOWS ONE THE MEASURE PASSES.
MOVING ON NOW TO FILE ITEM ONE
TWENTY SEVEN SENATOR WINNER YOU
PREPARE FOR THIS ITEM SECRETARY
PLEASE READ. ASSEMBLY BILL
SIXTEEN THIRTY EIGHT BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER OBERNOLTE AND
EXPLAIN TO SEARCH WARRANTS
SENATOR WINNER I THANK YOU
MISTER PRESIDENT I'M PRESENTING
THIS BILL ON BEHALF OF ASSEMBLY
MEMBER OBERNOLTE THIS BILL
GIVES LAW ENFORCEMENT AUTHORITY
TO OBTAIN TO SEEK AND OBTAIN A
SEARCH WARRANT IN ORDER TO
ACCESS THE EVENT DATA RECORDER
EDR DATA. IN VERY LIMITED
CIRCUMSTANCES INCLUDING WHEN AN
ACCIDENT RESULTS IN DEATH OR
SERIOUS BODILY INJURY AND ONLY
DURING THE COMMISSION OF A
MISDEMEANOR OFFENSE AND EIGHTY
ARE AS AN AUTOMATED AN
AUTOMOTIVE LOCK BOX THAT'S
OFTEN INSTALLED IN NEWER MOTOR
VEHICLE MODELS AND WHICH
CAPTURES APPROXIMATELY FIVE
SECONDS OF DATA. DURING A
COLLISION THE STATE I CAN
INCLUDE INFORMATION REGARDING
THE VEHICLE SPEED BRAKING
STEERING SEATBELT USE AND OTHER
PERMANENT FACTORS CRITICAL TO
EATING AN OFFICER DURING AN
INVESTIGATION ABOUT A
COLLISION. AB SIXTEEN THIRTY
EIGHT IS VERY NARROWLY DRAFTED
TO GIVE LAW ENFORCEMENT THE
STATUTORY AUTHORITY TO OBTAIN
INFORMATION FROM THE VEHICLES
ET ARE DURING THE COMMISSION OF
A MISDEMEANOR INVOLVING A MOTOR
VEHICLE COLLISION RESULTING IN
A PERSON'S DEATH OR SERIOUS
BODILY INJURY. LAW ENFORCEMENT
WOULD NEED A JUDGE TO ISSUE THE
SEARCH WARRANT AND THE OFFICER
WOULD ONLY BE ABLE TO ACCESS
INFORMATION RELATED TO THE
ACCIDENT IN ORDER TO AID WITH
THE INVESTIGATION THIS OCT
ACCIDENT RELATED AND
INFORMATION IS CRUCIAL TO
HELPING LAW ENFORCEMENT ACCESS
THE MOST SCIENTIFICALLY
RELIABLE EVIDENCE. TO CORRECTLY
IDENTIFIED BECAUSE. OF A
COLLISION I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR RIVAL. THANK YOU ANY
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THE
FINAL. SENIOR NON SECTOR PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL ALLEN. ARCHULETA
ATKINS I BATES I BILL I
PURCHASED. BRADFORD I CAMBIADO
I CHIANG I DALY I DODD I DORADO
I GALGIANI AYE GLAZER I
GONZALEZ. GROVE BY HERTZBERG I
HILL AYE HUESO TACO HI JACKSON
NO JONES. BY LEYVA AYE MCGUIRE
AYE MITCHELL. NO MONNING. NO
MORE LOCK. HIGH MORALE I
NIELSEN I PAN. BY PORTANTINO
ROTH BY RUBIO I SKINNER I STERN
BY STONE. I AM BURKE I WORK OUT
SEE NO WINNER I WILK HI HI.
SECTOR PLEASE CALL OUT TO
MEMBERS ALLEN. BY ARCHULETA
BURGESS HI. GONZALEZ. WITH SO
PORTANTINO. OUR EYES THIRTY TWO
KNOWS FOR THE MEASURE PASSES.
MOVING ON NOW TO FILE ITEM ONE
THIRTY TWO. SENATOR RUBY ARE
YOU PREPARED FOR THIS ITEM YES
I AM MISTER SECRETARY PLEASE
READ ASSEMBLY BILL FIVE FORTY
EIGHT BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
RODRIGUEZ AN ACT RELATING TO
INSURANCE. TO REVEAL THE FLOOR
IS YOURS. THANK YOU MISTER
PRESIDENT TODAY I RISE TO
PRESENT AB FIVE FORTY EIGHT
OTHERWISE KNOWN AS A BRACE AND
BOLD PROGRAM RUN BY THE
CALIFORNIA EARTHQUAKE
AUTHORITY. AN OFFICE OF
EMERGENCY SERVICES. THIS
PROGRAM OFFERS GRANTS TO
HOMEOWNERS THAT LIVE IN HIGH
EARTHQUAKE RISK AREAS TO
RETROFIT THEIR HOMES. THESE
GRANTS OVER 75% GRANT OVER 35%
OF THE COST IN UP TO THREE
THOUSAND DOLLARS. THE REST BY
HOMEOWNERS PAID AB FIVE FORTY
EIGHT ESTABLISHES SUPPLEMENTAL
GRANTS TO HELP LOW INCOME
HOMEOWNERS PAY THE DIFFERENCE
UP 290% OF THE TOTAL COST.
PREVENTING EARTHQUAKE DAMAGE IS
THE BEST WAY TO PROTECT
INDIVIDUALS AND OUR
COMMUNITIES. WE HAVE SEEN THE
TOLL EIGHT CATASTROPHE CAN TAKE
ON FIRE VICTIMS AND THEIR
COMMUNITIES. BY EXPANDING
ACCESS TO RESEMBLED GROUNDS
THIS BILL WILL HELP LOW INCOME
HOMEOWNERS AVOID THE LOSS OF
THEIR HOME AND HELP THEIR
COMMUNITIES AVOID THE LOSS OF
CITIZENS. BUSINESSES AND
RESOURCES THE BILL HAS NO
OPPOSITION AND HAS RECEIVED
UNANIMOUS SUPPORT I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR I POD
THANK YOU MISTER PRESIDENT.
THANK YOU ANY FURTHER
DISCUSSION AND DEBATE ON THIS
ITEM. SENIOR NON SECTOR PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. I'M SORRY THIS
IS ALSO FOR YOU NATURAL CALLS
OR ANY OBJECTION VIEWS AND YOU
NATURAL CALL IN THIS ITEM. SHE
NINE. OZ THIRTY SEVEN NO ZERO
THE MEASURE PASSES. MOVING ON
NOW TO FILE ITEM ONE THIRTY
NINE. SENATOR STONE ARE YOU
PREPARED FOR THIS ITEM. YES
MISTER PRESIDENT MISS SECTOR
PLEASE READ SOME OF ELEVEN
SIXTY EIGHT BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
MULLIN AND ACT REALLY INTO
EMERGENCY SERVICES CENTERS
STONE THANK YOU MISTER
PRESIDENT AND COLLEAGUES I'M
VERY PROUD TO BRING FORWARD AB
ELEVEN SIXTY EIGHT ON BEHALF OF
ASSEMBLY MEMBER KEVIN. MULLIN
AB ELEVEN SIXTY EIGHT WOULD
REQUIRE THE OFFICE OF EMERGENCY
SERVICES TO IMPLEMENT A TEXT IN
REAL TIME TAX THE NINE ONE ONE
SERVICE TO. ALL COUNTIES BY
TWENTY TWENTY ONE. REAL TIME
TAXES A TEXT TRANSMITTED
INSTANTLY AS IS BEING TYPED
RECIPIENTS CAN IMMEDIATELY READ
THE MESSAGE WITHOUT WAITING.
THIS BILL WOULD BENEFIT THE
DEAF AND HARD OF HEARING
COMMUNITY BY PROVIDING EQUAL
ACCESS TO EMERGENCY SERVICES
WHEN THEY DON'T HAVE ACCESS TO
TT WISER VIDEO RELAY SERVICES.
AND CALIFORNIA TT WHY IS A
VIDEO RELAY SERVICES ARE THE
WAYS OF COMMUNICATING WITH
EMERGENCY DISPATCHERS WHEN IN
NEED OF HELP FOR THE DEAF AND
HARD OF HEARING COMMUNITIES.
VIDEO RELAY SERVICES ARE
ACCESSIBLE THROUGH A THIRD
PARTY. AND IT ALLOWS THE
INTERPRETER TO SEE THE CALLER
BUT THE ACCESS TO NINE ONE ONE
THE SOMETIMES DELAYED. DUE TO
TRANSLATION VERSUS A DIRECT TAX
MESSAGE. AS NEW TECHNOLOGY
KEEPS ADVANCING TT TT WHY IS
pNOT THE MOST ACCESSIBLE FORMER
COMMUNICATION WITHIN THE DEAF
OR HARD OF HEARING COMMUNITY.
JUST LIKE PEOPLE IN GENERAL
THEY ARE RELYING ON INSTANT
MESSAGING TEXT MESSAGING EMAIL
OR VIDEO COMMUNICATION THROUGH
SMART PHONES OR COMPUTERS SAN
MATTEO AND SACRAMENTO AMONG THE
COUNTIES THAT HAVE IMPLEMENTED
TEXT A NINE ONE ONE
TECHNOLOGIES ALLOWING US TO
THIS IS TO REACH AN EMERGENCY
DISPATCH WHEN IT'S UNSAFE. OR
AN FEASIBLE TO CALL THIS
TECHNOLOGY WOULD ALSO BE
HELPFUL TO THOSE WHO FIND
THEMSELVES IN SITUATIONS WHERE
MIGHT BE TOO DANGEROUS TO DIAL
NINE ONE ONE SO THERE IS COULD
INCLUDE DOMESTIC VIOLENCE
INCIDENTS. ACCIDENTS ACOSTA
INABILITY TO SPEAK OR SHOOTER
INVOLVED SITUATIONS THANK YOU
MEMBERS I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR AYE VOTE. ANY FURTHER
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THE
SIDE ON. SCENE NINE THISIS
ELIGIBLE FOR UNANIMOUS ROLL
CALL IS THERE ANY OBJECTION
USING UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL ON
THE SIDE OF. SEE NINE OZ THIRTY
SEVEN NO ZERO THE MEASURE
PASSES. OUR MEMBERS ARE MY
TICKET OPPORTUNITY TO RECOGNIZE
A FORMER SIMPLY COLLEAGUES
BRIAN THIS DANTE LET'S GIVE HIM
A WARM SENATE WELCOME HERE
TODAY. NOW WE'RE MOVING ON TO
FALL ITEM ONE NINETY EIGHT
THERE MCGUIRE YOUR PREPARE FOR
THIS ITEM. MISTER SECRETARY
PLEASE THREE. ASSEMBLY BILL SIX
THIRTY FIVE BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
BIGELOW AND A CLEAN HORSE
RACING MAKING A PURPOSE IN
THERE FOR AND CLEARING THEIR
THROAT TO TAKE EFFECT
IMMEDIATELY SIR MCGUIRE THANK
YOU SO MUCH MISTER PRESIDENT
AND GOOD MORNING COLLEAGUES
TODAY LIKE THAT ARE PRESENT AB
SIX THIRTY FIVE BY THE GOOD AS
IN NUMBER SOME EVER BIGELOW
WHICH ADDRESSES A VERY SMALL
TECHNICAL CHANGE TO ENSURE ALL
FARES ARE ELIGIBLE TO APPLY FOR
FUNDS THROUGH THE FAIRS AN
EXHIBITION FIND CREATED BY A.
B. FOURTEEN NINETY NINE WHICH
WAS. ENACTED IN 200-017-8630
FIVE MAKES THE NEEDED TECHNICAL
ADJUSTMENT PROVIDING EXEMPTION
FOR EMPLOYEES UNDER A
COLLECTIVE BARGAINING AGREEMENT
I WOULD RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN
AYE VOTE. ANY FURTHER
DISCUSSION AND DEBATE ON THE
SIDE. MISTER TERRY PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL. THIS IS AGAIN I'M
SORRY THIS IS A CANDIDATE FOR
UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL IS THERE
ANY OBJECTION MUSING ANNOUNCE
ROLL CALL. SEEING NONE ICE
THIRTY SEVEN NO ZERO THE
MEASURE PASSED ON THEIR JINSHI
THE ICE THIRTY SEVEN NO ZERO ON
ITEM. I CONSIDER TO FORTY THAT
YOU YEAH OKAY I DIDN'T WRITE.
RIGHT MEMBERS WE'RE GOING TO
MOVE TO FILE ITEM TO FORTY ONE
WE'RE GOING TO GIVE CENTER
BRADFORD A MOMENT TO GET TO HIS
DESK OF MISTER SECRETARY PLEASE
READ. ASSEMBLY BILL FOUR
THIRTEEN. WHAT. WE HAD A LITTLE
KERFUFFLE APPEAR IT IS NOT
ELIGIBLE SENATOR BRADFORD COME
ON BACK UP HERE
. MEMBERS MOVING
ON NOW TO THE CONSENT CALENDAR.
SECRETARY PLEASE READ. ASSEMBLY
BILL FIFTEEN EIGHTEEN SENATE
BILL THREE SEVENTY NINE SENATE
CONCURRENT RESOLUTION
RESOLUTION SIXTY TWO ASSEMBLY
BILL THREE THIRTY TWO ASSEMBLY
BILL 640-678-7097. TWENTY EIGHT
EIGHT EIGHTY TEN EIGHTEEN TEN
SIXTY ONE TWELVE FIFTY ONE
EIGHTEEN HUND EIGHTEEN THIRTEEN. THANK
YOU. MEMBERS NOW RETURNING TO.
YEAH I'M SORRY YES THE SECTOR
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL ON THE
CONCERT CALENDAR. ALLEN. I ARE
SO THAT A ATKINS. I BATES I
BILL I PURCHASED I BRADFORD ART
I COME HERE I TING I DALY BY
DOT. HI THERE ALSO I GALGIANI
AYE GLAZER AYE GONZALEZ HI
GROWTH. I HERTZBERG AYE HILL
AYE HUESO. FOR TITLE I JACKSON
BY JONES I LEYVA. I MCGUIRE AYE
MITCHELL BY MORNING I'M MORE
LUCK I'M REAL AYE NIELSEN I PAN
AYE PORTANTINO ROTH BY RUBIO I
SKINNER AYE STERN AYE STONE. I
AM BURKE OUR COUNTY I WINNER BY
WILK HI. ICE THIRTY SEVEN NO
ZERO THE CONSENT CALENDAR IS
APPROVED. NOW MEMBERS REMOVING
A RETURNING BACK TO MOTIONS AND
RESOLUTIONS WE HAVE A NUMBER OF
JOURNEY MEMORIES. ARE WE
PREPARED. MADAM PROTIUM ARE YOU
PREPARED FOR YOUR JOURNEY
MEMORY. INTERACTIONS THANK YOU
MISTER PRESIDENT. I COLLEAGUES
ARE RISE TO ADJOURN IN MEMORY
OF GEORGE SHERMAN MISTER VEITCH
WHO PASSED AWAY WEDNESDAY JULY
TWENTY FOURTH AFTER A LENGTHY
BATTLE WITH CANCER JUST FIVE
DAYS SHORT OF HIS EIGHTY FOURTH
BIRTHDAY. A PROLIFIC WRITER
SPEAKER AND CONVENER GEORGE
LEFT A LASTING MARK ON SAN
DIEGO AS WELL AS NATIONAL
POLITICS AND BASEBALL. KNOWN
FOR HIS CIVILITY AND KINDNESS
GEORGE'S REMEMBERED AS A FRIEND
TO MANY HE WAS ON A FIRST NAME
BASIS WITH PRESIDENT'S FLIGHT
ATTENDANTS BOARD EXECUTIVES
LOCAL POLITICIANS AND BALLPARK
USHERS. GEORGE WAS BORN AND
RAISED IN SAN DIEGO WHERE HE
HELD A SERIES OF JOBS SUCH AS
WELDER MILKMAN. WHEN WE HAVE
THOSE BEFORE LAUNCHING HIMSELF
INTO NATIONAL POLITICS WHEN HE
JOINED SENATOR ROBERT F.
KENNEDY'S PRESIDENTIAL CAMPAIGN.
GEORGE WAS THERE WHEN SENATOR
KENNEDY WAS SHOT AND FIELDED
QUESTIONS FROM THE PRESS ON
THAT FATEFUL DAY HE WAS A
GIFTED ORATOR FOR OF HIS
SPEECHES WERE PUBLISHED IN THE
VITAL SPEECHES OF THE DAY. A
DISTINCTION HELD BY A FEW AND
PASSIONATE ABOUT CREATING
SPACES FOR PUBLIC DISCOURSE.
THIS FOCUS INSPIRED HIM TO
ESTABLISH THE CITY CLUB IN
NINETEEN SEVENTY FIVE A WELL
KNOWN NONPARTISAN PUBLIC FORUM.
THAT ATTRACTED SOME OF THE
FIRST BIG NAME POLITICIANS EVER
TO SAN DIEGO. EXAMPLES
PRESIDENT JIMMY CARTER US
SENATORS JOE BIDEN AND ALAN
SIMPSON AND JERRY FALWELL. I
HIS SLOGAN FOR THE CITY CLUB
WHICH HOSTED HUNDREDS IF NOT
THOUSANDS OF SPEAKERS WAS
DEDICATED TO THE DIALOGUE OF
DEMOCRACY. GEORGE BELIEVED IN
THE POWER OF RELATIONSHIPS AND
STATING GAUGE WITH HIS MANY
FRIENDS AND COLLEAGUES ACROSS
THE COUNTRY HE WAS GRACIOUS AND
IT WAS A GRACIOUS AND LOYAL
FRIEND TO MANY HE WILL BE
DEARLY MISSED. GEORGE ESTIMATES
OF ITS IS SURVIVED BY HIS WIFE
LIBERAL HIS THREE CHILDREN
CAROLINE MARK AND TIM AND THREE
GREAT GRANDCHILDREN COLLEAGUES
PLEASE JOIN ME IN HONORING THE
MEMORY OF GEORGE MITCHELL
MITCH. BOOKS AND ARE SENATE
CONDOLENCES TO THE FAMILY AND
BRING THE NAME PORTS ARE TO BE
PROPERLY MORE ALLIES. SENATOR
STONE. THANK YOU MISTER
PRESIDENT AND COLLEAGUES I RISE
TODAY TO ADJOURN THE SENATE AND
THE MEMORY OF A FRIEND CASE IN
A STERILE. THE FIRST WOMAN
ELECTED TO THE RIVERSIDE COUNTY
BOARD OF SUPERVISORS WHO SADLY
PASSED AWAY ON JULY TWENTY SIX
AT THE AGE OF EIGHTY ONE. BORN
IN NINETEEN THIRTY EIGHT K.
GRADUATED FROM LONG BEACH POLY
HIGH AND MET HER HUSBAND BLAIR
SENATE SERWIS WHEN BOTH
ATTENDED OCCIDENTAL COLLEGE.
THEY WERE MARRIED IN NINETEEN
FIFTY EIGHT MOVED TO RIVERSIDE
COUNTY IN NINETEEN SIXTY. IN
THE EARLY NINETEEN SEVENTIES
QUE WAS CONCERNED ABOUT
DEVELOPMENT PROPOSALS NEAR LAKE
HEMET AND VOICED HER OPINION AT
THE RIVERSIDE COUNTY BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS IN DOWNTOWN
RIVERSIDE. THE SUPERVISOR WAS
SO IMPRESSED WITH HER
PRESENTATION THAT NINETEEN
SEVENTY TWO THEY POINTED HER TO
THE COUNTIES PLANNING
COMMISSION THE FIRST WOMAN TO
HOLD THAT POSITION. HE SERVED
ON THE PLANNING COMMISSION VERY
YEARS IN THE NINETEEN EIGHTY
SIX SUCCESSFULLY RAN FOR A SEAT
ON THE BOARD OF SUPERVISORS THE
FIRST WOMAN TO BE ELECTED TO
THE COUNTY BOARD OF SUPERVISORS
AND RIVERSIDE COUNTIES OVER ONE
HUNDRED. YEAR HISTORY. SHE
SERVED AS A THIRD DISTRICT
SUPERVISOR THE SAME. DISTRICT
SUPERVISOR SEAT THAT I HELD FOR
THREE TERMS. PROVING HER
EFFECTIVENESS SHE WAS REELECTED
AS A THIRD DISTRICT COUNTY
SUPERVISORS THREE TIMES. K. WAS
KNOWN AND ADMIRED FOR BEING
FAIR SHE WAS STRONG ON POLICY
AND SHE DEEPLY CARED ABOUT THE
ENVIRONMENT IN A TIME OF RAPID
GROWTH IN RIVERSIDE COUNTY. SHE
WANTS TO HEAR HOW MUCH SHE
ENJOYED SOLVING PROBLEMS FOR
CONSTITUENTS. IN NINETEEN
NINETY CASE SUCCESSFULLY LED
THE EFFORT TO BUILD A MUCH
NEEDED SENIOR CENTER THAT WAS
BUILT IN THE AND INCORPORATED
VERY OF MENIFEE AND SUN CITY.
IT IS NOW KNOWN AS THE CASE IN
A STERILE SENIOR CENTER AND
OPERATED BY THE NOW CITY OF TO
MENIFEE. THE CENTER IS THE HUB
OF THE COMMUNITY ACTIVITY IN A
LARGE SENIOR POPULATION THAT
YOU DOES THAT FACILITY. THE
LARGEST OF ITS KIND IN THE
REGION. WHEN QUE RETIRED FROM
THE BOARD OF SUPERVISORS IN
NINETEEN NINETY SIX SHE QUICKLY
TOOK ON ANOTHER CHALLENGE. AS
DEAN OF AMOUNTS AND ACENTO
COLLEGE. OKAY WILL BE GREATLY
MISSED BY HER COMMUNITY THOSE
OF US THEY WERE LUCKY TO KNOW
HER WILL ALWAYS REMEMBER THE
POSITIVE EXAMPLE SHE SUFFERERS
I COUNTY. MEMBERS TODAY WE'RE
HONORED TO HAVE IN OUR PRESENCE
HER SON BRUCE SENATE SERWIS.
WHO IS HERE ON THE FLOOR OF THE
SENATE. THANK YOU FOR ALLOWING
ME TO ADJOURN THE SENATE MEMORY
AND RIVERSIDE COUNTY.
SUPERVISOR CASE IN A TERRACE
THEY GIVE US PRESIDENT THANK
CENTER STONE OUR STATE IN OUR
SENATE CONDOLENCES AND PLEASE
BRING AN IMPORTER CAN BE
PROBABLY MORE ALLIES. ALSO WANT
TO TAKE A POINT OF PERSONAL
PRIVILEGE AND RECOGNIZE OUR
FORMER COLLEAGUE BOTH IN THE
SENATE AND ASSEMBLY ARE
COUNCILMEN DEALS CISNEROS. I
MEET THE D. O. I'M SORRY THE.
DEALS WITH THE. HI. ARE A
SINNER A TOGGLE. THANK YOU
MISTER PRESIDENT TO COLLEAGUES
I ASKED WE ADJOURN TODAY'S
MEETING IN MEMORY OF THE LOVE
PILOT LIEUTENANT CHARLES WALKER
HE WAS THIRTY THREE YEARS OLD
COMMISSION IN TWO THOUSAND
EIGHT LIEUTENANT WALKER WAS
STATION IN SEVERAL PLACES
THROUGHOUT HIS SERVICE FROM
FLORIDA TO JAPAN BEFORE BEING
ASSIGNED TO THE VIGILANTES OF
STRIKE FIGHTER SQUADRON ONE
FIFTY ONE. BASED AT
CALIFORNIA'S NAVAL AIR STATION
Là MORE. LIEUTENANT WALKER WAS
COMMANDED BY CAPTAIN JAMES
BATES THE COMMANDER OF STRIKE
FIGHTER WING PACIFIC FOR SKILLS
AS A NAVAL AVIATOR AND WAS
CONSIDERED AN INTEGRAL MEMBER
OF DAVID. VINCULANTES
LIEUTENANT WALKER FELT. A DEEP
LOVE FOR HIS COUNTRY IN THE
SERVICE TO IT WILL NOT BE
FORGOTTEN PLEASE JOIN ME TODAY
AN ATTORNEY IN MEMORY OF
LIEUTENANT CHARLES WALKER FLEA
MORE NAVAL AIR. STATION THANK
YOU CENTER TADO ARTS SENATE
CONDOLENCES AND PLEASE BRING
THE NAME PORTS ARE CAN BE
PROPERLY MORE ALLIES BERMAN ON
SENATOR MORLOCK THANK YOU
MISTER PRESIDENT I'D LIKE TO
ADJOURN IN MEMORY OF ERIC
WOOLERY. HE IS THE ELECTED
ORANGE COUNTY AUDITOR
CONTROLLER. HE PASSED AWAY LAST
WEEK AUGUST SEVENTH IT WAS
UNEXPECTED IN A SHOCK TO ALL OF
US IN ORANGE COUNTY LEADERSHIP.
WAS ONLY FIFTY THREE YEARS OF
AGE. ERIC HAD BEEN UP HERE ON A
NUMBER OF OCCASIONS TO SUPPORT
VARIOUS BILLS AND LEGISLATION
SINCE HIS ELECTION IN TWENTY
FIFTEEN. HE WAS BORN IN
MISSOURI AND GREW UP IN THE
CITY OF ORANGE ATTENDED HIGH
SCHOOL THERE ANY GRADUATED FROM
CAL STATE UNIVERSITY FOR TWO
AND- AND IS CONTINUE TO BE A
RESIDENT OF THE CITY OF ORANGE.
HIT A SOLO PRACTICE AS A
CERTIFIED PUBLIC ACCOUNTANT.
AND IN THAT ROLE HE SERVED AS-
THE ORANGE THE CITY OF ORANGES
ELECTED CITY TREASURER. HE ALSO
WAS ELECTED TO THE ORANGE
COUNTY DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION
BOARD OF TRUSTEES. IN ANY
TRANSITION OUT OF A PRIVATE
PRACTICE AND WORKED FOR THE
DISTRICT ATTORNEY IN THE COUNTY
OF RIVERSIDE. AND TWENTY
FIFTEEN HE WOULD RUN FOR
AUDITOR CONTROLLER SUCCESSFULLY.
MR WILL RAISE WIFE AND
CHILDHOOD SWEETHEART LISA. IN
THE SMALL WORLD CATEGORY WAS MY
DAUGHTER'S. GRADE SCHOOL
TEACHER IN NINETEEN NINETY
THREE NINETY FOUR AND YOU MET
MY DAUGHTER THIS WEEK ON
MONDAYS SO WERE SORT OF
FAMILIAR WITH THE FAMILY IN A
KIND OF A UNIQUE SITUATION. HE
IS ALSO SURVIVED BY HIS
CHILDREN LIAM AND KATE AND WANT
TO REMEMBER THEM AT THEIR TIME
OF LOSS THANK YOU MISTER
PRESIDENT. THANK YOU CENTER
MORE LAW CAN WE EXTEND OUR
SENATE CONDOLENCES AND- ALSO I
SHOULD BRING A NAME FOR TOOK
CAN BE PROPERLY MEMORIALIZE
THANK YOU. SENATOR BATES. THANK
YOU MR PRESIDENT FIRST I'D JUST
LIKE TO ADD A PERSONAL NOTE ON
THE PASSING OF ERIC WOOLERY. I
HAVE TO SHARE WITH YOU HE WAS
ONE OF THE FINEST MINDS IN
TERMS OF FAIRNESS I IN OUR
POLITICAL ARENA HEARING THE
ETHICS COMMITTEE OF THE ORANGE
COUNTY. ARE CENTRAL COMMITTEE
ERIC WAS LED TO MANY REVIEWS OF
WHAT I WOULD CONSIDER TO BE
VERY HATEFUL OF POLITICAL. HIT
PIECES ON A NUMBER OF
INDIVIDUALS HE FELT THAT ARE WE
SHOULD RISE ABOVE THAT IN BE
FOCUSED ON POLICY DIRECTIVES.
CONTRIBUTIONS THAT INDIVIDUALS
HAD MADE ON THEIR WAY TO OUR
POLITICAL OFFICE AND I JUST
NEEDED TO ADD THAT BECAUSE HE
WAS A DEAR DEAR FRIEND. A DEAR
MAN AND SOMEONE WHO WILL BE
DEARLY MISSED I THINK IN THE
POLITICAL ARENA. ARE MY ADJOURN
SPECIFICALLY TODAY IS FOR ON MY
GOOD FRIEND JOE BROWN. HE
PASSED AWAY ON JUNE TWENTY
NINTH BORN NOVEMBER TWENTY
NINTH NINETEEN TWENTY SIX IN
FORT SMITH ARKANSAS. ODD TO JO
AND LUCY BROWNE. DURING WORLD
WAR TWO OUR SECOND WORLD WAR
JOE SERVED WITH THE AMERICAN
FIELD SERVICE AND ITALY IN
INDIA HE RECEIVED HIS BACHELOR
OF ARTS FROM YALE. MASTER OF
ARTS FROM USC AND A PHD FROM
USC HE WAS A CARING THOUGHTFUL
AND GRACIOUS MAN ALWAYS QUICK
TO RECOGNIZE. AND EXPRESSES
ADMIRATION FOR THE SKILLS AND
ACCOMPLISHMENTS OF THOSE AROUND
HIM. HE WAS A SUCCESSFUL
BUSINESSMAN HIS DRIED KEEN
BUSINESS SENSE AN EXCELLENT
LEADERSHIP SKILLS HELP TO
PREVAIL MANY OF THE COMPANIES
THAT HE LED AS PRESIDENT OR
VICE PRESIDENT TO NEW HEIGHTS.
WITH A CAREER THAT SPANNED
SIXTY EIGHT YEARS HE HAD THE
OPPORTUNITY TO WORK WITH A
VARIETY OF BUSINESSES AND
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA HE BELIEVED
VERY STRONGLY THAT GIVING BACK
TO THE COMMUNITY WAS OF THE
UTMOST IMPORTANCE. THIS WAS
DEMONSTRATED BY ITS EXTENSIVE
INVOLVEMENT IN CIVIC INCHER
CHURCH RELATED ACTIVITIES AND A
MEMBER OF THE ROTARY CLUB OF
WITHIN AND GAIL HE WAS PROUD OF
HIS YEARS OF SERVICE ON THE
CITY COUNCIL. OUR AS MAYOR O
LAGUNA MIGUEL IN AS CHAIRMAN OF
THE CITY FINANCE COMMITTEE AND
I MENTION THIS BECAUSE- JULES
FINANCIAL ACCU MEN CREATED I
THINK ONE OF THE- ONLY CITY
HALLS ABILITY IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA WITH CASH. A JOE
CHAIR THAT COMMITTEE AND WAS
ADAMANT THAT WHILE A CITY OF
OUR SIZE. IN WITH OUR RESERVES
SHOULD KEEP THOSE RESERVES FOR
THE RAINY DAY AND USE AVAILABLE
CASH A TWO FOR CAPITAL
IMPROVEMENT. IT'S A BEAUTIFUL
CITY HALL AND IF YOU'RE EVER
THREW Là GONNA GET ALL TAKE A
LOOK IS QUITE. QUITE LOVELY HIS
CONCERN FOR CHILDREN'S HEALTH
CARE KEPT HIM BUSY AS PRESIDENT
OF THE CHILDREN'S CLINIC AT
LONG BEACH MEMORIAL HOSPITAL.
CHAIRMAN OF THE BOARD OF
TRUSTEES OF MILLER'S CHILDREN'S
HOSPITAL AND DIRECTOR OF UNITED
CEREBRAL POLICY ASSOCIATION.
COMMITTED TO IMPROVING HIGHER
EDUCATION IN SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA HE WAS THE DIRECTOR
OF THE CALIFORNIA STATE
UNIVERSITY INSTITUTE. CHAIRMAN
OF THE BOARD OF DIRECTORS OF
CALIFORNIA STATE UNIVERSITY AT
DOMINGUEZ HILLS FUNDACION.
ENSURE OF THE FINANCIAL
COMMITTEE OF SADDLEBACK COLLEGE
FOUNDATION IN THE TO BENEFITTED
FROM JOE'S FISCAL ACCU MAN IN.
MANY IMPROVEMENTS AT THAT
COLLEGE ESPECIALLY OF FOR
VETERANS SERVICES. HE WAS ALSO
ACTIVE MEMBER OF THE LAGOON AND
GAIL PRESBYTERIAN CHURCH I ASK
THAT WE ADJOURN IN JOE'S MEMORY
ARE FINE FINE MAN LEAVES A- A
PLACE MISSING PLACE I IAN OUR
CIVIC LIFE. THANK YOU. THANK
CENTER VERY TWO WEEKS IN THE
SENATE. CONDOLENCES TO THE
BROWN FAMILY NASA TO BRING AN
IMPORTER CAN BE PROPERLY
MEMORIALIZED MEMBERS THERE'S NO
FURTHER BUSINESS INTERACTIONS
THE DESK CLERK. THANK YOU
MISTER PRESIDENT COLLEAGUES
HAVE A WONDERFUL WEEKEND AS WE
MOVE INTO THE NEXT WEEK OF. GET
IN A BUSIER AND BUSIER SO ENJOY
THE WEEKEND WE WILL SEE YOU
MONDAY AUGUST NINETEENTH. AT
TWO PM THANK YOU MISTER
PRESIDENT. THANK YOU THE SENATE
WILL BE IN RECESS UNTIL THREE
THIRTY WHICH TIME AND A GERMAN
MOTION WILL BE PLACED WE WILL.
RECONVENE ON MONDAY AT TWO PM
SENATE'S